RULES COMMITTEE TO ORDER. MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL ROLES
SENATORS BATES MINING. MINING
HERE ROTH ROTH HERE WELL CREDIT
WILL CARE ATKINS HERE ATKINS
HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE A
QUORUM AND I KNOW THAT A
SENATOR BATES IS ON HER WAY BUT
WE'RE GOING TO. GO AHEAD AND
GET STARTED HI BEFORE WE START
I WANNA A KNOWLEDGE SOMEONE
WHO'S WITH US TODAY. KIMORA
ROBERTSON IS HERE SHE IS AN
INTERESTING END UP MARK SHE IS
AN INTERN IN SENATOR SKINNER'S
OFFICE AND SHE IS GOING TO.
WATCH OUR I HEARING TODAY AND I
JUST WANTED TO WELCOME HER.
THANK YOU. SO I AM HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN A CONSENT AGENDA IN
HERE IS WHAT I UNDERSTAND CAN
BE ON THE CONSENT AGENDA. ITEM
NUMBER TWO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR ITEMS E. THROUGH OUR
HIGH IT WAS SEPARATE OUT J. E.
THROUGH BY. ITEM THREE BILL
REFERRALS ARE ITEMS FOUR AND
FIVE FLOOR ACKNOWLEDGMENTS
HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
MADAM SECRETARY WE CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS BATES MONNING
MONNING AYE ROTH. ROTH AYE WILK
NINE WILK AYE ATKINS HI INSIDE
AND WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR SENATOR BATES. I AND I WILL
NOW TAKE A MOTION FOR ITEM TWO
J. THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH MADAM
SECRETARY SENATORS BATES
MONNING. MONNING AYE ROTH ROTH
AYE WILK HI WILK I ATKINS TIME
ATKINS I. WE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR SENATOR BATES AND
THE SECRETARY WILL REMINDS ME A
SINCE I HAVE A TENDENCY. TO
FORGET. WITH THAT WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND CALL OUR FIRST TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE UP AND
THAT WOULD BE OUR SECRETARY. OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
MISTER RALPH TIAS. AND I
UNDERSTAND ARE THAT WEHAVE OUR
CABINET SECRETARY ANA MONTESANO
DOES HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE GOVERNOR
IN ADVANCE OF MEET OUR TURN IT
OVER TO MR TS. WELCOME THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR IT'S A
PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE AND IT'S A
PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE TO
INTRODUCE SECRETARY THE US. WE
AT THE GOVERNOR IS A VERY
EXCITED THAT RALPH IS TAKING
THIS CHALLENGE ON AND THAT HE
HAS BEEN LEADING IN THE WAY
THAT HE HAS. BY OVERHEAD THE
GREAT FORTUNE OF PRIVILEGE OF
GETTING TO KNOW RALPH. OVER A
FEW OF HIS TWENTY NINE YEARS
AND STATE SERVICE AND- IT'S YOU
KNOW TAKING ON THIS CHALLENGE
AND TAKING ON THE CHALLENGE OF
CHANGE IN THIS ORGANIZATION. IS
QUITE DIFFICULT PERHAPS ONE OF
THE HARDEST JOBS IN STATE
GOVERNMENT. SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES. THIRTY FIVE SMALL
CITIES. ARE TOO LITTLE JUST AS
FACILITIES THERE'S ALMOST NOT
WE CANNOT A WEEKEND THAT I
DON'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK TO RALPH ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT IS. THAT IS GOING ON. BE
IT A YOU KNOW CHALLENGES WITH.
YOU KNOW WITH VIOLENCE WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES WITH
DEALING WITH EMERGENCIES AND
FOLKS AT WITH THE S. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CARE FOR THEIR
WELL BEING IN THE CONTEXT OF.
YOU KNOW EARTHQUAKES ARE FIRES
OR- LEGIONNAIRES DISEASE AND
WORKING ON FIGURING OUT HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE. AND I GET TO TALK
WITH HIM HE ACTUALLY HAS TO HE
AND HIS TEAM ACTUALLY ROLL OUT.
AND DO THE RESPONSE SO WE AND
I'VE LEARNED A IN TERMS OF SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES OF WHAT
TRANSFORMATION REALLY MEANS IN
TERMS OF HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT.
HIS FOCUS ON KIND OF WHERE THE
RUBBER MEETS THE ROAD.
REHABILITATION AND EXPANDING
FUNDING FOR REHABILITATION
PROGRAM IS A CRITICAL THING BUT
IN ORDER TO REALLY MAKE IT
HAPPEN. AS I'VE LEARNED LIVES
ALL THE WORK AROUND MAKE. THAT
WE DON'T HAVE LOCKED DOWN SO WE
HAVE THREE FACILITIES THAT WE
HAVE IN A GREATER YARDS THAT
WE- ARE WORKING ON THE CHANGES
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE. SINCE
REALIGNMENT TO REALLY EXPAND
OPPORTUNITY AND RESTORE HOPE
AND I APPRECIATE. HIS
COMPASSION TOWARDS STAFF
COMPASSION TOWARDS INMATES AND
THE COMMITMENT TO. REALLY
PARTNER WITH IT WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND WITH YOU TOO.
TRANSFORMERS TWO SHINS AND TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE ARE BEING
PROVIDED THE OPPORTUNITIES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO EDUCATION TO
HAVE ACCESS TO JOBS TO. US SOME
OF THE INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS IN
TERMS OF HAVING FORMER
OFFENDERS COME BACK AND WORK
WITH. WITH OUR INMATES AND
SEEING THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
REALLY YOU KNOW SERVE THEIR
TIME AND USE THAT TIME TO TURN
AROUND THEIR LIVES TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM AND IT'S A PRIVILEGE
TO GET TO INTRODUCE THEM AND
IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO GET TO WORK
WITH THEM. I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISS WANT TO CENTOS.
LET ME TURN IT OVER TO YOU AND
AS TYPICALLY HAPPENS YOU GET TO
INTRODUCE ANYONE THAT MIGHT BE
HERE. TO SUPPORT YOU PERSONALLY
AND THEN GO RIGHT INTO YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT. I WILL GO
RIGHT TO QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
FROM THE MEMBERS. WELCOME TO I
THINK THE INTRODUCTIONS ARE IN
THE OPENING STATEMENTS ALL JUST
GO RIGHT IN THE OPENING
STATEMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
A FAR CRY FROM WHERE I GREW UP
IN SLAVERY COUNTING AND FAR
FROM. MY FIRST POST AND CDC ARE
AS A YOUNG CORRECTION OFFICER
ASSIGNED TO WATCH TOWER. EVEN
FURTHER FROM WHEN I WAS A
CAPTAIN A LEVEL FOR FACILITY AT
THE HEIGHT OF OVERCROWDING IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN ONE
CALIFORNIA PRISON POPULATION.
WAS A HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND INMATES. TODAY COME
BEFORE YOU IN THIS COMMITTEE TO
BE CONFIRMED AS THE FIRST
LATINO SECRETARY IN THE HISTORY
OF CORRECTIONS. MAYBE THE FIRST
LATINA SECRETARY WHO HAS
NEIGHBORS AND EVEN FAMILY
MEMBERS IN THE PRISON SYSTEM.
BY LISA FOR SECRETARY TO SPEAK
OPENLY ABOUT THEM AND HOW THESE
CONNECTIONS SHAKE MY
LEADERSHIP. AND THIS AGENCY.
BEFORE I BEGIN I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE SOME SPECIAL PEOPLE
IN SPECIAL PEOPLE IN MY LIFE.
MARIA MY WIFE OF TWENTY NINE
YEARS HAS BEEN MY MENTOR AND
COURAGE OR AND SPIRITUAL
MOTIVATOR. WITHOUT HER I COULD
NOT HAVE WEATHERED THE
CHALLENGES OF THIS CREATURE IN
CORRECTIONS. MY CHILDREN
ADRIANA AND VINCENT WHO HAVE
SACRIFICED AT TIMES NOT BY
HAVING THEIR FATHER PRESENT
MENTALLY AND SOMETIMES
PHYSICALLY. THERE NOW TO
SERVICE TO THE PUBLIC IN THEIR
OWN CAREERS I COULD NOT BE MORE
PROUD OF THEIR ACHIEVEMENTS. MY
MOTHER DIANA AND STEP FATHER
GEORGE. GEORGE IS A RETIRED
ARMY VETERAN AND RECENTLY
RETIRED PUBLIC SERVANT. MY
MOTHER WHO RECRUITED ME IN THE
CDC ARE WHO STARTED HER CAREER
IN CDC ARE NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX.
AND RETIRED AS A SERGEANT AT
SAN QUENTIN STATE PRISON IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE. SHE WAS
THE FIRST EXAMPLE OF AN ONE
OFFICER SHOULD BE IN
CORRECTIONS. MY FATHER RALPH
WHO PASSED SEVERAL YEARS AGO
WHO INSPIRED ME TO BE THE BEST
WORKER I COULD. WHO RAISED ME
TO BE THANKFUL FOR THE
SACRIFICES OF MY GRANDPARENTS.
WHO LABOR IN THE FIELDS OF THE
WESTERN UNITED STATES IN HOPES
OF A BETTER LIFE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN AND GRAND CHILDREN. I
KNOW THAT ALL WOULD BE PROUD OF
ME TODAY. LASTLY I WANT TO
EXTEND MY APPRECIATION TO
GOVERNOR KNEW SOME. FIRST
CONFIDENCE IN ME FOR POINTING
ME TO THIS POSITION. I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION TO CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE OUR CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM
FOR YEARS TO COME. TODAY
CALIFORNIA'S INMATE POPULATION
IS BELOW ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND FOR THE FIRST
TIME SINCE JUNE OF NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR. ALMOST FIFTY
THOUSAND OFFENDERS LESSON SEVEN
YEARS AGO. LET'S CROWDING AS
LEAD TO MORE SPACE AND WE'RE
PROUD TO HAVE CREATED MORE
PROGRAM OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
REHABILITATION TO BE OFFERED IN
THAT SPACE THIS CHANGE HAS LEAD
TO FEWER INCIDENCE. MODIFY
PROGRAMS FEWER STAFF ASSAULTS
AND THESE PROGRAMS OF HELP
CREATE AN INMATE POPULATION
THAT IS HOPEFUL. AND PLANNING
FOR THEIR RELEASE. IT IS ALSO
LED TO A WORKFORCE THAT IS
REDEFINING THE MEANING THE
PUBLIC SAFETY BEYOND
INCARCERATION. I UNDERSTAND THE
PUBLIC SAFETY. MEANS MENTORING
AND ROLE MODELING AND HAVING
COURAGEOUS INTERACTIONS WITH
INCARCERATED HERE SOME EXAMPLES
OF OUR PROGRESS WE HAVE FIVE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED. FACE TO
FACE COLLEGES JUST A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO WITH A HANDFUL OF
PROFESSORS TEACHING IN PRISON
ONLY CORRESPONDENCE COURSES.
AWARDED OVER FOUR THOUSAND
YEARS OF CREDIT UNDER PROP
FIFTY SEVEN INMATES HAVE EARNED
THESE CREDITS BY PARTICIPATING
IN EDUCATION VOCATIONAL TRADES
AND SELF HELP GROUPS. WE ARE
VACATED ALL OUT OF STATE BEDS
AS OF JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN. ALTHOUGH EACH OF
THESE IS TRAGIC WE'RE ON TRACK
TO HAVE FEWER HOMICIDES IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN FEWEST
SUICIDES FEWER OVERDOSES AND
FEWER ESCAPES. WE HAVE RELEASE
THOUSANDS OF INMATES FROM
RESTRICTED HOUSING WE HAVE OVER
THREE HUNDRED LIFE FOR INMATES
AND LOW LEVEL FACILITIES
MENTORING AND BEING POSITIVE
ROLE MODELS TO YOUNGER INMATES.
WE ARE CREATING A MORE WE
CREATE MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
VICTIM OFFENDER DIALOGUES NOW
BRING VICTIMS TOGETHER CORPS
COMMIT WHO'VE COMMITTED CRIMES
AGAINST PEOPLE SO THEY CAN
COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR
RELATIVES ARE THEMSELVES. WERE
MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
BEHAVIOR PACE MODEL THAT
PROVIDES MORE FLEXIBILITY ON
HOW WE HOUSING WHERE WE HOUSE
INMATES RATHER THAN THE OLD
POINT SYSTEM TO DETERMINE WHERE
INMATES ARE HOUSED. WE HAVE
OVER FOUR THOUSAND INMATES OF
THE PLACE AND LOWER LEVEL
FACILITIES AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND WHO HAVE RECEIVED
CUSTODY LEVEL REDUCTIONS BASED
ON NEW REGULATIONS. WE ARE I
BELIEVE AT THE FOREFRONT OF THE
NATION REGARDING THE TREATMENT
AND HOUSING OF TRANSGENDER
INMATES. AND WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A MULTI
COLLABORATIVE COMMITTEE TO
EVALUATE GENDER AFFIRMING
SURGERY AND REQUEST FOR HOUSING
IN THAT POPULATION. ALTHOUGH I
ADMIT WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO.
AND PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
REWARDING DAILY TASKS THAT I
HAVE A SECRETARY BEGAN
EXERCISING. THE STATUTORY
STATUTORY AUTHORITY MEAN
BOARDING THAT RECOMMEND THAT
ALLOWS ME TO RECOMMEND TO THE
COURTS. THE NIGHT THAT THEY
REVIEW SENTENCING DISCREPANCIES
RETROACTIVELY CHANGES IN LAW
AND REWARDED MAKES FOR
EXCEPTIONAL CONDUCT. CCAR'S
MAILED OVER ONE THOUSAND
LETTERS. AND OVER AND IN OVER
THREE HUNDRED CASES JUDGES HAVE
RECALLED IN RE SENTENCE IN
MASON REDUCE TERMS BY OVER ONE
THOUSAND YEARS. ALTHOUGH THESE
DEVELOPMENTS HAVE BOGGLE MY
MIND AS A YOUNG OFFICER AS A
SECRETARY I RECOGNIZE THAT IT
IS MOTIVATED INMATES TO DO
BETTER AND STAFF TO RECOGNIZE
THEIR EFFORTS AND MANY OF THOSE
STAFF AND LEADERS ARE HERE WITH
ME IN THIS ROOM TODAY. I WANT
TO SAY THAT THESE MONIES THE
THESE CHANGES THAT WE'VE DONE
WOULD NOT HAVE TAKEN PLACE OF
WORN OUT FOR THESE DEDICATED
STEP THAT ARE SITTING HERE AND
WATCHING ONLINE. MY CITY SEE
OUR FAMILY IS HERE AND I NEED
TO LET THEM KNOW THAT PROGRESS.
THIS PROGRESS THAT WE MADE IS
ONLY THE BEGINNING. WE MUST
LOOK FOR THEM TO GET DITIONS OF
CONFINEMENT AND THE CARE OF
TREATMENT OF INMATES AS
INDIVIDUALS PROGRAMS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE THE ATTITUDE OF
THIS IS THE WAY IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN JUST DOESN'T CUT ANY
CORRECTIONS ANYMORE. WE
CONTINUE TO BATTLE ISSUES OF
ADDICTION AND GANG CULTURE. WE
MUST WORK HARDER TO TREAT IN A
CULTURE REHABILITATION AND
HEALING. SO THAT KNOWN YOU
VICTIMS ARE CREATED WE MUST PAY
CLOSE ATTENTION. TO THE
WELLNESS OF STAFF. STRIVING FOR
THE HEALTH AND EXCELLENCE OF A
WORK FORCE. THE REWARDS ARE
FROM WHICH PEOPLE OF ALL
GENDERS RACE OR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. THESE ARE
STRESSFUL JOBS AND STAFF NEED
SUPPORT. I'M PROUD THAT IN A
RECENT CONTRACT WE'VE INCREASED
THE NUMBER OF FEMALE SPECIFIC
POST AND CREATED. THE FIRST
EVER LABOR MANAGEMENT WORK
GROUP DEDICATED FOR RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION OF FEMALE STAFF.
I STILL MUCH TO LEARN AS AN
EXECUTIVE AND I WELCOME YOUR
ADVICE. BUT AS LONG AS I'M
SECRETARY OF THIS GREAT AGENCY
THAT I DO LOVE I HOPE THE MY
LASSEN IMPACT IS TO REFUSE TO
OUR STAFF AGAIN WITH THE
PURPOSE THE FELT ON THE DAY
THAT THEY GRADUATED FROM THE
ACADEMY OR THE DAY THEY JOINED
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
THEY GOT INTO THIS BUSINESS TO
CHANGE LIVES. I HOPE THAT WHEN
THE MEN AND WOMEN. THAT ARE
INCARCERATED IN THIS SYSTEM ARE
RELEASED THEY CAN LEAD
PRODUCTIVE LIVES AND READ AND
NOT RETURN TO PRISON. GOVERNOR
SOME WANTS TO CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE CDC ARE AND I WANT TO
HELP THEM. I HOPE YOU'LL GET
THIS OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SECRETARY SENATOR MONNING LET
ME START WITH YOU TODAY. THANK
YOU MADAM PRO TEM AND MR DHEAS
ANA CONGRATULATE YOU ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR YEARS OF DEDICATED SERVICE
AND ALSO YOUR FAMILY FOR THEIR
SUPPORT IT'S DEFINITELY A- TEAM
EFFORT IN TEAM SACRIFICE. IN
YOUR OPENING STATEMENT YOU
REFERENCE SOME OF THE
SENTENCING REFORM PROP FIFTY
SEVEN I'M WONDERING IF YOU
COULD SHARE IF YOU'VE OBSERVED
ANY CHANGES IN TERMS OF
INTERNAL SAFETY FOR IN MAINE
STAFF IN GUARDS. BASED ON
SENTENCING REFORMS THAT HAVE
GIVEN. INMATES PERHAPS CAUSE
FOR HOPE NANA THAT RESULTS IN
BEHAVIOR I HAVE SEEN GIANT
SENATOR COULD YOU SHARE SOME OF
YOUR OF THE CHANGES THAT I HAVE
SEEN IS THE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
BEEN ESTABLISHED AND PUT INTO
PLACE BY CORRECTIONS THROUGH
THE DIVISION OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS COUPLED WITH OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS THROUGH OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT OF PEOPLE COME IN AND
FACILITATE PROGRAMS AND INMATES
NOT PARTICIPATE IN THEIR TRUE
MEANINGFUL PROGRAMS ARE IN
MAYES COME IN. THEY THE STAFF
AND THE VOLUNTEERS A
FACILITATOR THEY RECEIVE
CURRICULUM THAT THE OTHERWISE
WOULDN'T RECEIVED IN THE
COMMUNITY OR OTHERWISE IN YEARS
PAST THESE INMATES EARN CREDITS
FOR THEM THE MONITORED AND I
USE THE TERM EARNED WE DON'T
GIVE THEM ANYTHING WHAT WE HAVE
SEEN THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
PROGRAMS IN PRISONS LIKE NO
OTHER WITH ESTABLISH DOG
PROGRAMS ANTI GANG PROGRAMS
BEHAVIOR BASED ENGINE NOT TO
WERE IN MAYES CAN THINK
DIFFERENTLY. PROGRAMS OR WE CAN
EMBRACE THEIR CULTURE THEIR
BACKGROUNDS WE HAVE SEEN
CHANGES IN HOUSE STAFF INTERACT
WITH THE INMATES BECAUSE THEY
SEE IN MAKES HIS YEAR THERE WAS
A DAY WHEN INMATES WOULD JUST
SIT ON THE DATA SAID ON THE DAY
ROOM FLOOR JUST READ CREATE ON
THE ART IN MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
GOING TO PROGRAM WHAT THAT DOES
IS ESTABLISHES A MORE HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT AS I TO THE PRISONS
I WITNESSED IT MYSELF. THANK
YOU IN YOU REFERENCED I THINK
SOME OF THE WITH RESPECT TO THE
TRAINING PROGRAMS HOW WOULD YOU
DESCRIBE THE UTILIZATION OF
OUTSIDE NONPROFITS VOLUNTEERS
SIN HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE YOUR
RELATIONSHIP FOR THOUGHTS
REGARDING THE ROLE OF. SOME
OUTSIDE ORGANIZATIONS.
INTERACTING WITH INMATES IN
TERMS OF EDUCATION AND
REHABILITATION. I REALLY VALUE
OUR PARTNERS OUR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS ARE
VOLUNTEERS THAT COME IN I THINK
ONE OF THE MOST. ONE OF THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL THINGS THAT
WOULD OTHER THAN AGENCIES
WELCOME THE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED TO COME BACK AND
FACILITATE SOME OF THESE
COURSES TO THE INMATE
POPULATION. AND I THINK THIS I
KNOW WHAT THIS DOES IS BRINGS
CREDIBLE MESSENGERS TO THE
INMATES BUT THEY CAN SPEAK OF
THE NEW HOPE THAT IS OUT THERE
IN THE COMMUNITY AND ENCOURAGE
THEM TO PARTICIPATE IN PROGRAMS
AND THAT THE PROGRAM THAT
THEY'RE IN. THAT IT DOES MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IF PEOPLE ARE
WATCHING SO THAT IN ITSELF TO
HAVE FORMALLY INCARCERATED
COMING BACK IN AND SPEAKING
POSITIVE YOU INTO THESE LIVES
BUT THEN ALSO THE STAFF THAT
WITNESS SOME OF THE INMATES THE
FORMALLY CULTURE TO THE COME
BACK. THEY MAY HAVE THEY MAY
HAVE OVERSEEING THEM MAYBE SIX
MONTHS AGO A YEAR AGO AND IT IS
GOOD TO SEE THE FRUITS OF THAT
WORK SO FOR ME THAT IS THE
THAT'S A CULTURE SHIFT INSIDE
THE INSTITUTIONS. I WELCOME
MORE WE DO HAVE CHALLENGES A
SOME MORE RURAL AREAS WE'RE
MAKING HEADWAY OUT THERE. THANK
YOU IN. WHEN WE HAD A CHANCE TO
TALK MOM. I RAISED AN ONGOING
CONCERN I KNOW IT'S A SHARED
CONCERN OF. CONTRABAND COMING
INTO THE PRISONS FROM. DRUGS
WEAPONS CELL PHONES THAT CAN BE
WEAPONIZED IN A SENSE. IN
THERE'S VERY HIGH SECURITY AND
SCRUTINY OF FAMILY MEMBERS
VISITING DURING VISITING HOURS
BUT I THINK IT'S BEEN FOUND
THAT SOME OF THE HOLES IN THAT
SECURITY ARE WITH STAFF
EMPLOYEES EVEN GUARDS BRINGING
IN CONTRABAND. WHAT WILL YOU DO
TO. THAT. THAT SUSCEPTIBILITY
IN OUR SYSTEM THAT AFFECTS THE
SAFETY OF INMATES GUARDS AND
STAFF I THINK ONE ONE THING
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE DONE WE
HAVE A TWO YEAR PILOT THAT ONE
INSTITUTION AT THE- CALIFORNIA
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
FACILITY IN CORCORAN TO WHERE.
WE HAVE EVERY STAFF MEMBER
COMING IN IS SEARCH SIMILAR TO
WHAT THE WAY YOU'D BE SEARCHED
IN AN AIRPORT WE HAVE INCREASED
BAGGAGE CAN LIVE INCREASE STAFF
TO WERE AND STAFFING TO WERE
STE STAFF CAN BE SEARCH MORE
CLOSELY. WE NEED TO MOVE
FURTHER ALONG THOSE ALONG THAT
TRACK BUT I NEED TO HAVE THE
DATA AT THIS ONE PILOT TO MAKE
SURE WE MOVE FORWARD. IN AN
EFFICIENT AND A FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE WAY. I THINK THAT
WAS A DAY IN IN MY OWN TEN YEAR
I WOULDN'T I WOULD HAVE
CHALLENGE ANYONE THAT AND STAFF
ON INVOLVED IN THIS BUT-
UNFORTUNATELY I'VE HAD THE
EXPERIENCE AND HAVE SEEN THE
STAFF TO GET INVOLVED IN THIS.
AND I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
STAFF MEMBER THAT WOULD AGREE
THAT THAT'S A GOOD THING I
BELIEVE THE STAFF TO DO THIS.
FOR THE RIGHT REASONS TO CHANGE
LIVES AND HAVE A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT THEY SUPPORT THE
EFFORTS TO. ROOT OUT STAFF WHO
ARE WHO ARE ENGAGING IN THIS
ACTIVITY. WHEN WAS THE PILOT AT
CORCORAN BE COMPLETED WHEN YOU
HAVE DATA TO LEARN I SHOULD
HAVE DATA BY NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY. IN WHAT'S THE PROSPECT
FOR EXTENDING. THOSE PROTOCOLS
AT CORCORAN TO ALL MMHM
SECURITY FACILITIES AND IS
THERE ANY RESISTANCE FROM STAFF
OR BARGAINING UNITS TO
INSTITUTE STRICTER FROM ENTRY
AND EXIT CRITERIA I THINK THE
RESPONSIBLE THING FOR ME TO DO
IS TO LOOK AT THE DATA WHEN IT
WHEN WE GET FINISHED WITH THAT
PILOT AND THEN MAKE DECISIONS
BASED OFF THAT DATA. I DON'T
WANT TO ENTER INTO ANYTHING
GREATER THAT'S GOING TO MAKE A-
PUT A DENT IN THIS BUDGET OR
ASK FOR RESOURCES THAT I CAN'T
WITH CONFIDENCE SAY THAT THIS
IS THE WAY TO GO MAYBE I CAN
USE PIECES. OF THIS PILOT BUT
NOT THE WHOLE THING. I HAVE
WORKED CLOSELY IN THE
DEPARTMENTS WERE CLOSELY WITH
LABOR. WITH THE BARGAINING
UNITS AND I BELIEVE THAT THEY
ARE ON BOARD WITH HAVING SAFE
INSTITUTIONS. THERE ARE SOME
CHALLENGES WITH. JUST WITH THE
CONCEPT OF SEARCHING THE THOMAS
OF THE DO WE TRUST AFTER NOT.
AND IT DIDN'T AND I THINK THE
CASE IS. WE ARE WANTING SAY
FACILITY IS NOT A MATTER OF
TRUST IT'S ABOUT TO MATTER OF
SAFETY THAT'S ABOUT
COMMUNICATING TO OUR LABOR
PARTNERS ON WHY WE'RE DOING
THIS. THANK YOU IN. AGAIN
YOU'VE CITED CORCORAN IS A
PILOT PROGRAM ARE THERE ON
GOING SECURITY PROTOCOLS THAT
THE OTHER PRISONS DESIGNED TO.
INTERCEPT CONTRABAND WHATEVER
VIA WHATEVER ROUTE IT MIGHT BE
ENTERING WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
CANINE PROGRAM THAT IS A STATE
WIDE PROGRAM STATEWIDE EFFORT
AND THAT DOES WE HAVE
DESIGNATED STAFF ON A STATEWIDE
BASIS THAT GOAL FROM PRISON TO
PRISON. UTILIZED DOGS TO SEARCH
OUT CELL PHONES TO SEARCH OUT
CONTRABAND THE DEPARTMENT HAS A
POLICY AND IT'S ON THAT WE DO
RANDOM SEARCHES OF STAFF ON A
HOLISTIC LEVEL WE MAY JUST SLOW
DOWN THE SEARCH STAFF IN A MORE.
IN A SLOWER WAY IN A MORE
DETAILED WAY FROM TIME TO TIME
AS PART OF OUR PROTOCOLS I
THINK ANYTHING WE VENTURE INTO
THE HOUSE TO BE DATA DRIVEN AND
HAS TO BE A BEST PRACTICE. BUT
I DON'T WANT TO LOSE INTEREST
TO SOMETHING THAT FOUR YEARS
DOWN THE ROAD SAY IT DIDN'T GET
DIDN'T GET THE RESULTS YOU WANT
BUT WE SPENT A LOT OF MONEY
THANK. BEEN UNDER CURRENT
PROTOCOLS. IS IT. IF YOU
DETERMINE THAT A STAFF MEMBER
IS SMUGGLING CONTRABAND IS THAT
GROUNDS FOR TERMINATION YES IT
IS IT AUTOMATIC TERMINATION
THEY HAVE TO PROCESS LIKE A AN
EMPLOYEE THEY HAVE AN
INVESTIGATORY PROCESS AND WE
PUT WHEN THEY HAVE THEIR RIGHTS
AVAILABLE TO THEM WITH
REPRESENTATION. BUT IN THE END
BUT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
PREVENT STAFF AND TO TOUR
STAFFER PARTICIPATE IN THIS IN
THE END ANY CONTRABAND THAT
COMES IN IS DANGEROUS. THE IN
MY POPULATION THERE IS A HIGH
VALUE DOLLAR TO THESE ITEMS AND
IT DISRUPTS ARE REHABILITATED
PROCESSES IN A REALIZE YOU MAY
NOT HAVE AT YOUR FINGER TIPS
TODAY BUT COULD YOU GET US. ANY
DATA THAT WOULD REFLECT SOME
DISCIPLINE IN ORDER MANY
NATIONS OF STAFF RELATED TO
CONTRABAND OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS YES I CAN APPRECIATE.
THANK YOU AND THEN. MY FINAL
QUESTION I KNOW THERE'S. THE
INQUIRY THAT IS THE SUBJECT OF
LITIGATION BUT IN YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT AND I DON'T INTEND TO
GO INTO AREAS OF ACTIVE
LITIGATION WITH SPECIFICS. IN
YOUR OPENING STATEMENT YOU DID
TALK ABOUT YOUR COMMITMENT. TO
ADVANCING IN PROTECTING
DIVERSITY AND GENDER EQUITY IN
RECRUITMENT IN RETENTION IN AND
PROMOTION COULD YOU SHARE WITH
THE COMMITTEE WHAT SOME OF
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE IN IN YOUR
BROADER COMMITMENT MOVING
FORWARD AND TO GUARANTEE. THAT
EQUITY AND LEGAL PROTECTIONS IN
RECRUITMENT RETENTION AND
PROMOTION. SO THIS ISSUE IS OF
MY HIGHEST PRIORITIES AND I
TAKE THIS VERY SERIOUSLY ONE OF
THE FIRST THINGS I DID AS A
SECRETARY WHEN PRESENTED WITH A
PRESENTATION FROM A GROUP
CALLED THE GOVERNMENT ALLIANCE
ON RACE AND EQUITY IS PRESENTED
TO ME AND THAT WAS. HAS BEEN
PRESENTED TO ALL STATE AGENCIES
TO SEE WHO WOULD PARTICIPATE
AND WHAT THAT GROUP IS TEN IS
SO WE CAN EXAMINE INTERNALLY
WITH OUR DATA ON A HIRING
PRACTICES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS NO PLACE IN BY IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE HIGHER
WRITTEN. A STE LOOKS LIKE A
STAFF THAT COVERS A WHOLE SPAN
OF OUR COMMUNITIES WE WANT A
DIVERSE COMMUNITY WE WANT AND
GENDER A GENDER. A STEP THAT'S
LOOKED BEYOND GENDER BECAUSE
THE QUALITIES AND SKILLS THAT
COME TO US ARE ARE DIVERSE JUST
LIKE OURS. IN MY POPULATION IS
DIVERSE THEY COME FROM ALL OVER
THE STATE. AND I WANT A
WORKFORCE THAT LOOKS LIKE THAT
DIVERSE WORKFORCE. SO I TOOK
THAT ON MY SPONSORED THAT GROUP
THE DEPARTMENT NGUYEN
WHOLEHEARTEDLY. SINCE THEN
WE'VE BEEN TWO YEARS INTO THAT
GROUP. I SHIP THAT THAT GROUP
UNDER OUR OFFICE OF CIVIL
RIGHTS WILL OVERSEE IT. THE
GROUP WILL BE MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE OFFICE
OF CIVIL RIGHTS WILL THEN FOR
THEM UP. TO MYSELF AND OUR HR
SO WE CAN MAKE THE NECESSARY
CHANGES. ONE THING THAT I I'M
WELL AWARE OF AS A TOURING THE
INSTITUTIONS. AND NOT HAVING TO
HAVING GROWN UP IN THIS
BUSINESS I AM LOOKING FOR A
WORK FORCE EXECUTIVES LEADERS
SUPERVISORS AND EVERYWHERE IN
BETWEEN. A ROOM THAT JUST
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE ME I'M
LOOKING FOR A ROOM AND LEADERS
THAT LOOK LIKE CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE WITHIN THAT DIVERSITY
WE HAVE IDEAS WE HAVE COURAGE
WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO WILL SPEAK
OUT OPENLY AND THINK
DIFFERENTLY. ONE THING THAT WE
HAVE ALREADY SEEN WITH THIS
GROUP IS NOT A PRESENTATION WAS
GIVEN TO WARDENS. AND IT WAS A
VERY UNCOMFORTABLE CONVERSATION
WITH THESE WARDENS THAT THEY
HAD TO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT WE'RE FACING THE
SOME OF THE INITIAL DATA IS. WE
NEED TO DO BETTER. ON WHO WI
HIGHER. AND WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE PEOPLE
HAVE VALUE AND THE TAP THE
HIGHER. NOT JUST BASED ON WHAT
THEY SEE EVERY DAY WE HAVE TO
BRING IN. A DIVERSITY OF
INDIVIDUAL SO WE CAN HAVE A
GOOD GROUP. IT IS ONE OF MY
HIGHEST PRIORITIES TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE A DIVERSE WORKGROUP I
AM. AS I SAID IN MY OPENING
STATEMENT MY MOTHER RECRUITED
ME INTO CDC ARE. AND I'M WELL
AWARE OF MY MOTHER'S TRIALS AS
YOU NOTED SHE RETIRED AS ST
QUITTING BUT- WE ARE FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. SHE HAD TO GET
HER TO SAY QUITTING BECAUSE SHE
COULDN'T. IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. I'M SURE SHE WOULD
RATHER GUN HIRED IN THE CENTRAL
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY BUT SHOULD
TAKE ABORTIONS AND QUICK. I
DON'T KNOW THE DETAILS OF IT
BUT I KNOW IT WAS A CHALLENGE
AND I KNOW. IF SOME OF THESE
MEASURES COULD'VE BEEN A PLACE
MAYBE MONICA STATE HOMES THAT A
COME UP TO SAN QUENTIN. THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR CANDOR IN
RESPONSE TO MY QUESTIONS AND-
WE JUST ASK MAYBE IS MY FINAL
QUESTION. YOUR COMMITMENT IF
CONFIRMED. TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE LEGISLATURE. IN WORKING TO
ACHIEVE GOALS THAT I THINK BY
YOUR OWN STATEMENT HAVE NOT YET
BEEN ACHIEVED IN. THE REALM OF.
RECRUITMENT RETENTION AND
PROMOTION. YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT SENATOR THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEMP. THANK
YOU I'M GONNA SKIP OVER YOU
SENATOR BATES AND SHE JUST GOT
HERE AND I WILL COME BACK TO
YOU AND I WILL GO TO OUR VICE
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
APPRECIATED OUR OUR OUR OUR
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
APPOINTMENT THAT REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT YOU TOOK A LOT
OF TIME TO TALK ABOUT
REHABILITATION. WE NEED TO DO
MORE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HIT
THE PEOPLE ON END UP THERE BUT
WE ALSO NEEDED A QUICK THESE
PEOPLE SO THEY CAN BE
PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
WHEN THEY GET OUT. SO HAVING TO
DO WITH THAT IN IN JANUARY THIS
YEAR THE STATE AUDITOR CAME OUT
WITH A REPORT IT WAS KIND OF
CRITICAL. OF THE OVERSIGHT.
THAT THE DEPARTMENT'S BEEN
DOING REGARDING REHABILITATION
SO I KNOW IF YOU YOU READ THAT.
DID YOU AGREE WITH THAT OF
OTHERS ARE YOU TAKEN STEPS TO
MAYBE. ADDRESS SOME OF THE
INADEQUACIES THAT WERE LISTED.
I HAVE WRITTEN I AGREE WITH
PORTIONS OF THE REPORT. I DO
WELCOME ANY AND ALL CRITICISM
THE REPORTS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
BECAUSE I THINK WE NEED THEM.
WE HAVE TO SEE THINGS ONLY
BECAUSE IN THE END YOU KNOW WE
WERE HERE TO SERVE THE PUBLIC.
THE PEACE OF THE REPORT THAT I
DIDN'T AGREE WITH I THINK THAT
WITH THE MAIN FOCUS OF THE
REPORT WAS A WORK COGNITIVE
BEHAVIOR PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE
IS ALMOST NEARLY 70% OF THAT
REPORT. BUT IT ALSO CHALLENGE
US TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE REST
OF OUR REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS.
SO FOR AS AN AGENCY IT IS OUR
GOAL NUMBER ONE TO REHABILITATE
THE INDIVIDUALS AND THAT ARE
GOT PUT IN THE CDC AREN'T TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX. UNFORTUNATELY
THE RECESSION CAME UPON.
SHORTLY AFTER WAS DECIMATED A
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS WE
BUILT UP. SINCE THEN AND-
THAT'S REFLECT A LITTLE BIT IN
THAT REPORT. I DO BELIEVE THAT
REHABILITATION IS OUR NUMBER
ONE GOAL IN THE PRISON SYSTEM.
AND MORE POORLY TO HAVE THE
MOST VALUABLE. TOOL OUT THERE'S
OUR OUR STAFF MEMBERS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT'S THE ROLE. AND
WHAT ROLE THAT THEY PLAY IN
REHABILITATION. SO I THINK THE
FUNDING THAT WE'VE BEEN
RECEIVING. AND WE HAVE RECEIVED
I THINK IT IS GOING INTO. IS
BEING INVESTED PROPERLY JUST AN
EDUCATION PIECE TWO THOUSAND IN
NINETEEN ALONG WE HAD OVER
THREE THOUSAND GED OR HIGH
SCHOOL EQUIVALENCIES EARNED A
TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN WE
HAVE THIRTY THIRTY FOR FACE TO
FACE COLLEGES. THE WATER SYSTEM
LIKE I MENTIONED EARLIER. AND
JUST IN THIS YEAR ALONE WE HAVE
OVER TWO HUNDRED A. A.'S EARNED
JUST. WITH OUR COLLEGE PIECE
FIVE BACHELOR'S DEGREES AND
THEN TO POST GRADUATE DEGREES.
I THINK EDUCATION IS THE KEY TO
ANYBODY SUCCESS IF YOU CAN
LEARN SELF ADVOCATE FOR
YOURSELF. YOU WILL HAVE LESS
ISSUES. RETURN INDIVIDUALS FOR
PAROLE TO THE VOCATIONAL SIDE I
BELIEVE AND I KNOW THAT WE DO
HAVE PROGRAMS ON THE VOCATIONAL
SIDE THAT ARE PREPARING
INMATES. IN THE MOST CURRENT
TECHNOLOGIES AND WE ARE MEETING
INDUSTRY STANDARDS IN THE
CERTIFICATIONS THAT THEY DO
RECEIVE. THE NATIONAL
RECOGNIZED ANYWHERE FROM SOLAR
SOLAR INSTALLATION ELECTRONICS
AND WIRING IN AN INSTALLATION
TO AUTO REPAIR WE WE'RE NO
LONGER INTO THE BUSINESS OF
FIXING CARBURETORS WEIRD
TRAINING IN MAY SADDAM. RIPPER
HYBRID VEHICLES. WE RECENTLY
CUT A RIBBON ON A PROGRAM AT
SOLEDAD STATE PRISON ON THE
BUILDING OF MICRO HOMES. FOR
YEARS OF TERROR IN MADE
CONSTRUCTION AND HOW TO BUILD
STRUCTURES PLUM THEM YEAH.
INSTALL ELECTRICITY BUT NOW
IT'S GOING TO BE MORE
MEANINGFUL AT THAT INSTITUTION
THEY CAN BILL MICRO HOMES OF
THE USE IN THE COMMUNITY. SO
WITHIN CONSTRUCTION ALL OF
THESE INDUSTRIES THAT I
MENTIONED THEY ARE. FRIENDLY TO
THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN FORMALLY
INCARCERATED AND WE HAVE SEEN
SUCCESS I'M EXCITED TO SAY THAT
THIS MORNING. AN AGREEMENT WAS
SIGNED ON A DATA SHARING
AGREEMENT THAT SO WE CAN TRACK
OUR SUCCESSES NOT ONLY IN
EDUCATION. BUT THE WORK FORCE
AND H. R. SO OUR PAROLEES WHEN
THEY DO INTO THE WORK FORCE OR
EDUCATION WE TRACKED THEIR
SUCCESS WITH SECOND BETTER.
ASSIST US AS AN AGENCY. TO FIND
TO WHAT WE'RE DOING ON THE
RETAIL SIDE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
ANSWER AND HONESTLY I THOUGHT
FEDERAL CENTER MONEY DID A
FABULOUS JOB SO HE TOOK ALL MY
QUESTIONS I WAS THE ONLY ONE I
HAD. SO BUT AGAIN AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU. I'LL LET
YOU GO FIRST MET NEXT TIME
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN. HE TOOK A
NUMBER OF MINE TOO BUT I FIGURE
BY THE TIME IT GETS TO ME
YOU'VE ASK ALL THE QUESTIONS
SENATOR ROTH. THANK YOU A MAN
PRO TEM. A MISTER SECRETARY
CONGRATULATIONS SIR YOUR RESUME.
AND BACKGROUNDER QUITE
IMPRESSIVEAND FRANKLY MY
ADMITTEDLY. CURSORY REVIEW I
GUESS YOU WOULD SAVE YOU
PROGRAMS YOU'VE LAUNCHED A
KNOWS YOU PLAN TO LAUNCH.
CERTAINLY THOSE ALSO APPEAR TO
BE QUITE IMPRESSIVE. I HAVE
ACTUALLY NO. FURTHER QUESTIONS
AT THIS TIME UNFORTUNATELY
DURING THE. PRE HEARING
INTERVIEW PROCESS I AS FOR HIS
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE
DEPARTMENTS AND INTERNAL
COMPLAINT AN INVESTIGATION
PROCESS WHICH YOU YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO ANSWER AT LEAST AT THIS
POINT IN TIME. I HAVE TO SAY
THAT I DO THINK AS A MEMBER OF
THIS COMMITTEE IN A- ELECTED
SENATOR IN THIS BODY I DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THIS
CONFIRMATION PROCESS IN. THIS
COMMITTEE'S ROLE IN THAT
PROCESS TO BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY
BY ALL. ALL THE ALL WHO WERE
INVOLVED AND FOR MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO FULLY
EXPLORE. IANY AND ALL ISSUES
THAT ARE PRESENTED BY AN
APPOINTMENT AN ATTEMPT TO GET.
ANSWERS TO THOSE ISSUES OR
QUESTIONS THAT ARISE. FIVE
SINCE I'VE BEEN ON THIS
COMMITTEE WE CERTAINLY. ATTEMPT
TO DO SO BUT- HAVING SAID THAT
AND NOT WITHSTANDING THAT
ASSUMING THERE IS A MOTION I
WILL BE VOTING. TO MOVE YOUR
NOMINATION TO THE SENATE FOR A
TO PERMIT FURTHER DISCUSSION.
AND A VOTE OF BY MY COLLEAGUE
SO AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS. I
LOOK FORWARD TO READING MORE
ABOUT YOUR INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS
IN YOUR SUCCESSES. AT THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE FUTURE THANK
YOU CENTER LIKE ABOUT BRIDGE.
THANK YOU SENATOR OFF. SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU ARE MADAM
CHAIR AND OF WELCOME MISTER
DIAZ WE HAD A NICE DISCUSSION I
THINK OF MY COLLEAGUES OF
COVERED A COUPLE OF THE ISSUES
IN PARTICULAR I THINK AS A
FORMER SOCIAL WORKER WE SHARED
OF OUR MUTUAL OF CONSIDERATIONS
CONCERNS ABOUT GETTING PEOPLE
BACK YOU KNOW TO PRODUCTIVE
PART OF SOCIETY AND CERTAINLY
THAT YOU ARE TOTALLY FOCUSED ON
THAT I THINK A IN MY
CONVERSATION WITH YOU I DID
MENTION THAT ARE SENATOR SPENT
QUITE A BIT OF TIME. THE LATTER
PART OF LAST YEAR IN THE FIRST
PART OF THIS YOU'RE LOOKING AT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ISSUES AND
ENSURING THAT WE HAD A PROCESS
THAT TO A FAIRLY FOR BOTH ON
BOTH SIDES OF AN ISSUE THE
ACCUSED IN THE ACCUSER WERE
DEALT WITH FAIRLY NOW THE THAT
IS AN ISSUE THAT YOU'RE DEALING
WITH CERTAINLY AND I THINK MY
QUESTION WAS KLAY WHAT WHAT ARE
YOU DOING TO ENSURE THAT CHILD
TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
COMPLAINTS ARE DEALT WITH AND
WHAT IS THAT PROCESS AND WITH
GENDER DISCRIMINATION WHICH IS
KIND OF A CADA. SO IF YOU WILL
OF THE SAME ISSUE AREA. WOULD.
SHARE WITH US SOME OF THE
THINGS SHE SHARED WITH ME. OUR
HOW YOU'RE ADDRESSING THAT IN
ENSURING THAT OUT TO YOU STAFF
AND YOU HAVE. YOUR YOUR
EMPLOYEES WHICH ARE HUGE. ARE
ALL RIGHT ON THE RIGHT PAGE ON
HOW WE DEAL WITH THOSE THINGS
IN OUR- IN OUR LEGISLATURE AND
CERTAINLY IN OUR STATE AGENCIES.
SO I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
AND WE DO HAVE A PROCESS IN
PLACE. THAT IS A PROCESS THAT.
THERE'S SEVERAL WAYS THAT AN
EMPLOYEE CAN FILE A COMPLAINT
OR EXPRESS A CONCERN ABOUT AN
ISSUE. THE WE HAVE INTERNAL
FILING PROCESSES AND THAT'S DEL
THROUGH OUR LOCAL INTERVENTION
PROCESS AT THE FACILITY LEVEL
AND THE FIELD LEVEL. THE
EMPLOYEE CAN ALSO GO TO THE
OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS
OPERATIONS IN OUR HEADQUARTERS
LEVEL OR THEY CAN ALSO FILED
FOR THROUGH INTERNAL EXTERNAL
AGENCIES THROUGH DFG H. R. E.
E. O. C. OF THE DEPARTMENT DOES
TRAIN OUR STAFF ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS. THAT'S PART OF OUR
ANNUAL BLOCK TRAINING ON HOW
EMPLOYEES ARE TO CONDUCT
THEMSELVES WITH AND ALSO HOW
SUPERVISORS ARE TO. RECEIVE
THESE COMPLAINTS. ONCE A
COMPLAINT IS RECEIVED BY A
SUPERVISOR THE IMPORT OF THE
SUPERVISOR HAS THE OBLIGATION
AND THEY HAVE THE DUTY. TO
REPORT THIS TO THE OEO
COORDINATOR OF THE OF THE FEEL
THAT I I'M STAYING AWAY FROM
INSTITUTION BECAUSE JUST SAYS.
THE BIG SPENCER CORRECTIONS TO
THEIR EAGLE COORDINATOR. AND
FROM THERE THE IO COORDINATOR
THEN RECEIVES A COMPLAINT. WE
HAVE THE REASON WE HAVE TO GIVE
SOMETHING BACK TO THE COMPLAIN
WITHIN SEVENTY TWO HOURS THE
GOAL OF THIS PROCESS NUMBER ONE
IS TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES AT THE
AT THE LOWEST LEVEL POSSIBLE SO
WE CAN GET IMMEDIATE RESULTS WE
CAN HAVE A HEALTHY. AND THEN
DISCRIMINATION FREE WORK
ENVIRONMENT WE WANT TO GET
THROUGH THAT PROCESS SO IF
SOMEONE WHO IS DOING THINGS
THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF POLICY WE
NEED R. E. O. CORNISH TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE TO TAKE
REMEDIES TO SEPARATE THE- THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO WHO'S OFFENDING.
TO POSSIBLY EVEN PUT HIM ON HBO
BUT IN THE END THEY HAVE THEIR
DUE PROCESS RIGHTS ALSO SO WE
NEED TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
BUT THEN IF WE THROUGH THAT
PROCESS FIND THAT THERE ARE
ISSUES THAT IS ELEVATED UP AND
IT GOES TO YOUR COORDINATORS.
AND THROUGH THAT THEY DO
FURTHER INVESTIGATION IT IN
COURT RECEIVE ALL INFORMATION
AND WITH THAT PROCESS AND IS
GIVEN OVER TO HER IN THE
FORTIES TO SEE WHAT DIRECTION
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO GO TO WE
GO INTO A MORE FORMAL INTERNAL
AFFAIRS INQUIRY. AND THOSE IN
CORY'S CAN LEAD FOR EVERYTHING
FROM TERMINATION TO FINDING
THAT THERE ARE NO THAT THEY
COULDN'T FIND ANYTHING IN THE
CASE AND PAINTING AND
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN. SO THERE
IS A PROCESS IN PLACE I'M
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE IT
WILL BE IMPLEMENTING THE NEW
DISCRIMINATION IN SYSTEM THAT
IS A STATE WHERE ALL HAVE TO
IMPLEMENT AS CHALLENGES TO THE
GRAVITY AND THE LARGESS THE
STATE OF THE. I'M GONNA
CORRECTION THE NOW WE THE
MINUTE BUT I HAVE MY TEAM.
DEDICATED ON THAT AND I'VE HAD
MEETINGS WITH THEM THE LAST
SEVERAL DAYS TODAY SURE ME. AND
DESCRIBE TO ME HOW THIS WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED ONE OF THE MOST. I
THINK. THINGS WERE GOING TO DO
ONCE WE IMPLEMENT THIS SYSTEM.
IS WE WILL BE REMOVING. THE E.
E. O. COORDINATOR WHO DOES
RECEIVE THE COMPLAINTS FROM THE
COUNSELORS. OUTSIDE OF THE FEEL
THEY WILL BE REGIONAL ALLIES
IT'LL BE AN INDEPENDENT ENTITY
TO REVIEW WHAT IS RECEIVED. AND
THEY WILL TAKE A LOOK. IT WILL
NO LONGER JUST BE WITHIN THE
FIELD FOR HIGHER THAN THIRTY.
RECEIVES IT MAKES AN ASSESSMENT
IT WILL NOW BE WITH THE
COORDINATOR WHO THEN REPORTS OR
OFF THE CIVIL RIGHTS AND HEAD
QUARTERS. SO I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO THAT. AND IN THE END
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS LOOK AT
THE DATA THAT WE RECEIVE. LOOK
AT THOSE ANY TRENDS THESE ARE
EARLY DECATUR SO WE CAN MAKE
TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTION IF WE SEE
AN AREA. A DIVISION IN THIS
AGENCY IS NOT DOING WELL BUT
THE MORE POORLY AS A SECRETARY
I SPEAK OUT DIRECTLY. I SPEAK
OUT ON A REGULAR BASIS AND WHAT
THE EXPECTATION IS. AND I KNOW
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE WATCHING
ONLINE RIGHT NOW ON NO BUT.
THIS IS THE HARDEST PART FOR
THE AGENCY. AND THAT'S WHAT I
EXPECT. THE PRIEST. THAT ANSWER
UP. IN CHILE YOU ON YOUR ON
NOMINATION ON MY PROBABLY WILL
KIND OF. FIVE FIRST HERE ON
TIME VERY INTERESTED EXCITED
ABOUT YOU KNOW SEEING THE
TRACKING AS YOU IMPLEMENT THE
PLAN JUST LIKE WE HAVE DONE
HERE ARE WITH OUR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. AND I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE DOING IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE YOU'RE
SABOTAGING TRUST AMONG YOUR
EMPLOYEES AND ALSO WITH THE
PUBLIC WHICH IS WHERE YOU KNOW
WE'RE ALL WHILE WE'RE THEIR
SERVANTS SO THANK YOU ARE A
GREAT RESUME AND YOU'RE NOT YOU
WILL BE BEFORE THE SENATE FLOOR
YES I MIGHT BE CHATTING WITH
YOU BETWEEN NOW AND THEN. LOOK
FOR THE COVER SAKE YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I THINK LET'S
SEE MY COLLEAGUES OF COVERED
ALMOST EVERY TOPIC. THAT WE I
KNOW HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
FOR QUITE SOME TIME I WANT TO
JUST ADD ONE MORE QUESTION
RELATED TO THE TRANS GENDER
INMATES AND STAFF I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTING ON THE STATUS
OF THE WORKING GROUP ON
TRANSGENDER INMATES. I GUESSI
WOULD ASK I WANT TO PUT STAFF
IN THAT CATEGORY TOO IF THEY'RE
TRANS GENDER STAFF MEMBER. I
GENDER NON CONFORMING HI WE
LIVE IN A FLUID WORLD. AND WE
HAVE TO ADJUST OUR ALL OF OUR
PERSONNEL IN NATURE POLICIES
MUST ADJUST WITH THAT AS WELL I
AM INTERESTED TO KNOW WHAT
EXPERTS OR- MEMBERS OF
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS THAT
REPRESENT. RANGE GENDER GENDER
NON CONFORMING ARE YOU SEEKING
TO BE PART OF THAT. EITHER THE
EITHER THE WORKING GROUP OR TO
PRESENT TO THE WORKING GROUP
HAS THAT HAPPENED ALREADY OR
THEIR PLANS TO THE THERE ARE
THERE ARE PEOPLE WE HAVE SOUGHT
OUT NOTHING MOST IMPORTANTLY IS
THE INMATE POPULATION SPEAKING
TO THEM WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE
WHAT THE INPUT IS ON THE POLICY
THAT WE'RE GONNA STAB WISH. BUT
I THINK EARLIER ON E HAD WE
THOUGHT OUT PEOPLE TO COME IN
AND WE HAVE A TRANS GENDER MALE
BUT ADRIN LAWYER WHO CAME IN
FROM NEW MEXICO TO GIVE
TRAINING. ON. ON WHAT THE
POLICY SHOULD LOOK LIKE HOUSE
STAFF ARE TO TREAT AN ****
REALLY TOUGH QUESTIONS. HE CAME
AND PROVIDED TRAINING TO MY
EXECUTIVE TEAM HERE IN
HEADQUARTERS HE PROVIDED
TRAINING TO OUR- TO OUR
WARDENS. AND IT WAS REAL IT
REALLY OPENED UP A LOT OF EYES.
AND I THINK THROUGH THAT
TRAINING WERE ABLE TO ASK A LOT
OF QUESTIONS AND ENCOURAGE
QUESTIONS. BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S WHERE WE HAVE TO HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING. THAT THIS. THE
SEGMENT OF OUR POPULATION
REALLY DESERVES HONOR DIGNITY
RESPECT AND TO BE TREATED AS
ANYONE ELSE. AND THE TO DISPEL
ANY CONCERNS THAT MAY BE OUT
THERE. AND I THINK AT TIMES
WERE JUST AFRAID TO ASK
QUESTIONS SO FOR ME THAT WAS
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS TO COME
IN. AND TALK TO US. IN THE WORK
GROUP THE TRANSGENDER WORKGROUP
I ATTENDED A PIECE OF THAT WORK
GROUP LAST WEEK WE DID HAVE.
SOME PARTNERS IT DID COME IN. I
COULD GET YOU THE NAMES OF
THOSE I KNOW THERE AT THE TABLE
I DIDN'T HAVE TIME TO GET TO ME
THAT BUT I DEFINITELY WILL GET
YOU THE NAMES OF THOSE.
INDIVIDUALS JUST THE
CONVERSATION THAT THEY HAD ON
SOME OF THE POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE VERY
FRUITFUL. AND BRINGING THINGS
UP THAT WERE OUTSIDE OF A
CORRECTIONS AND A GOVERNMENTAL
MINDSET THAT WE NEEDED TO BE
COMPETENT AT THESE ISSUES AND
IF THEY WEREN'T THERE. WE WILL
SKIP OVER. WE MANAGEMENT ISSUES
AND WE MAY HAVE A- IN A ONCE
AGAIN MARGINALIZE. A GROUP EVEN
MORE BECAUSE WE ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES. THANK YOU I'M JUST MAKE
A FEW COMMENTS AND THEN GO TO
THE SPEAKERS AS SUPPORT YOU
KNOW I BY THE WAY I WANT TO SAY
I APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS
ALWAYS TO COME IN AND MEET WITH
ME REGARDLESS OF WHEN I WAS A
SENATOR WHEN YOU WERE A AT
VARIOUS LEVELS AND I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY SO BEFORE I WAS PRO
TEM I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO COME IN AND WORK
WITH ME AS A MEMBER ON ISSUES I
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT LEGISLATION
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT
THANK YOU FIRSTLY. WE OF. AS A
RESPONSE TO AND WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF OTHER SENATORS. YEAH
WE REPRESENT THEM AND- I CAN'T
SPEAK FOR MY REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES BUT I KNOW ON THE-
DEMOCRATIC SIDE WE HAVE. A
POLICY RETREATS AND AS DO YOU
AND- THE WORK DONE AT CDC ARE
IS OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE TO MY
COLLEAGUES. AT WHICH IS
PROBABLY WHY YOU SEE WE HAVE
MANY MORE ISSUES ARE. ARE
RELATED TO MAYBE THE WORK THAT
YOU DO YOU HAVE A LOT OF
INMATES ARE ALL ACROSS THE
STATE A LOT OF. FACILITIES AND
SO IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THEM. AND
THE GOVERNOR OF COURSE IS
INDICATED THAT THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
APPOINTMENT AND I COULD NOT
AGREE MORE. THE MEASURE OF OUR
SUCCESS AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY
ON THIS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE OF REHABILITATION AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM. OUR
SUCCESS IS BASED ON YOUR
SUCCESS YOU'RE ACTUALLY DOING
THE WORK AND SO FOR US TO TAKE
THE TIME TO GO THROUGH THESE
THINGS I KNOW YOU UNDERSTAND
GIVEN YOUR HISTORY SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. THERE'S SO
MANY ISSUES FACILITIES NEEDS WE
TALKED ABOUT THAT ONCE A YEAR
OR SO AGO I THINK WE'VE GOT A
AND I APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE PUTTING SOME RESOURCES
TOWARD SAID. WE ARE NEVER GOING
TO REHABILITATE PEOPLE IF WE
PUT THEM IN FACILITIES THAT
DON'T REFLECT OUR DESIRE. TO
REHABILITATE PEOPLE KNOW WHEN
THEY THERE IS A CONCERN ABOUT
THE MAN WHEN THERE IS AND I
THINK WE'VE GOT TO DEAL WITH
THE FACILITIES ISSUES THE
TRAINING NEEDS. ARE CRITICAL.
PART OF THE PLAN. I APPRECIATE
YOUR APPROACH WE CAN HAVE
IDEALS AND GOALS BUT IT'S UP TO
US TO MAKE IT REAL I APPRECIATE
MY COLLEAGUE TALKING ABOUT THE
WORK THAT WE'VE HAD TO DO OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS AND WE
HAD TO LOOK OURSELVES IN THE
MIRROR. AND SEE THAT WE HAVE
MAJOR CULTURAL. SCHIFF SAID
NEEDS THAT WE NEED TO WORK ON
AND IT'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT
PAINFUL BUT I THINK YOU HAVE A
MUCH BIGGER TASK THAN WE DO.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE MORE. INMATES
ARE WHO ARE NOT EXACTLY THERE I
THROUGH THEIR VOLUNTEERISM. HI
AND YOU'VE GOT STAFF SO. I DO
THINK THAT'S WHY WE TAKE THIS
SO SERIOUSLY. AND I WILL JUST
LEAVE IT THERE WE HAVE PLENTY
OF PEOPLE THAT WANT TO SPEAK
BUT I DO WANT TO THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S.
APPOINTMENTS I WILL SAY THIS TO
THE PUBLIC WE HAVE IN ADDITION
TO THE PEOPLE IN HERE WE HAVE
FORTY FIVE OTHER PEOPLE OUTSIDE
WHO ARE HERE IN SUPPORT. LET ME
JUST KIND OF GET AND HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE HERE IN THE AUDIENCE
OUT HERE IN OPPOSITION. OKAY.
SO HERE'S WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
SUGGEST TYPICALLY WE GIVE OUR
PEOPLE TWO MINUTES I AM GOING
TO CUT THE SUPPORT SIDE I WOULD
LIKE YOU BECAUSE IN AN INTEREST
OF FAIRNESS AND THAT WE HAVE
OTHER APPOINTEES I'M GOING TO
ASK YOU TO GIVE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR SUPPORT I REALLY AM NOT
GONNA GIVE YOU TWO MINUTES I'M
PROBABLY NOT EVEN GOING TO GIVE
YOU ONE SO IT IS SO. I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT IF YOU. I'M SURE
YOU'LL DO IT ELOQUENTLY AND
YOUR NAME AND YOUR PRESENTATION.
PLEASE GO AHEAD I WANT TO CUT
OFF PEOPLE BUT I THINK WE'LL
GET THE GIST OF WHO'S HERE AND
WHO YOU REPRESENT. AND IT WILL
TAKE THAT TO HEART WELCOME
THANK YOU MADAM ROAD TO MY NAME
IS CLARK KELSO I'M THE RECEIVER
IN CHARGE OF MEDICAL CARE
WITHIN CDC ARE I PREVIOUSLY
SUBMITTED A LETTER OF SUPPORT
TO YOUR OFFICE EARLIER THIS
WEEK I JUST WANTED TO BE HERE
TODAY IN PERSON TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK. YES MA'AM HI
MY NAME IS NORMA COMPOUND THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION AND
WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT AND WE
ARE ONE OF THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT GOES BACK INTO THE
INSTITUTIONS TO BRING HOPE AND
REDEMPTION AND AS SOMEONE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED I LOVED
WHAT I HEARD HERE TODAY AND I'M
VERY EXCITED TO CONTINUE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH CDC ARE.
THANKS CONGRATULATIONS. THANK
YOU. HELLO ROBERT SELF OF
FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR VETERAN TELLING VETERANS
FROM THE INSIDE OUT WERE IN
FIVE PRISONS NOW I GO BACK IN A
FACILITY I SPENT TWENTY THREE
YEARS IN PRISON. MISUSES ONE
THE FIRST PEOPLE I MET WHEN I
WENT TO PRISON AND HE SAID
SOMETHING TO ME VERY IMPORTANT
BACK THEN. AND THAT WAS YOU'RE
BETTER THAN THIS AND YOU CAN DO
BETTER THAN THIS AND THAT
STAYED WITH ME THE ENTIRE TIME
I WAS IN. THE DIRECT RESULT OF
PROGRAM. AND I'M IN SUPPORT.
YES MA'AM GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS PRISCILLA MUST GROW AND
I'M A RETIRED CDC ARE.
SUPERVISOR I WAS WHEN HIS FIRST
CORRECTIONAL COUNSELOR
SUPERVISORS AT SATURDAY AND I
JUST WANTED TO SAY I AM SO
HONORED A VERY PROUD OF YOU
ROUTE. THIS MAN. SO DEDICATED
HE'S SO COMMITTED HE IS VERY
VERY VERY VERY VERY VERY CARING.
I RESPECT AND ADMIRE HIM
BECAUSE THE LOVE HE HAS FORCE
FAMILY AND HIS FRIENDS NOT ONLY
HIS FAMILY WAS FRANCE BUT HIS
CDC OUR FAMILY. WHEN I FIRST
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY HE WALKED
INTO THE OFFICE EVEN THOUGH
HE'S SITTING HERE ALL
CONFIDENCE. HE WALKED IN VERY
VERY SHY AND NERVOUS AND I TOLD
ME JUST SIT BACK AND RELAX AND
WHEN YOU'RE READY. WE'LL
PROCEED WITH THE QUESTIONS ANY
DID EXACTLY THAT. AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY TO YOU ROUND. I
KNEW YOU COULD DO IT. THERE'S
NO BETTER PLACE FOR YOU TO BE.
IT IS YOUR TIME. AND I AM SO
PROUD OF YOU AND I JUST THINK
YOU OFFER ALLOW ME TO BE HERE
TO SPEAK ON HIS BEHALF. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. YES SIR GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU. MY NAME.
IS MORE SOME EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION I'M ALSO A FORMER
LIFE FOR A SERVE TWENTY FOUR
YEARS INSIDE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS. DROP D. IS. THE
LEADER FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS WE RUN THE HOPE OF
REDEMPTION TEAM INSIDE OF NINE
STATE PRISONS INCLUDE PELICAN
BAY IN CORCORAN FORMER LIFE IS
GOING BACK INSIDE FACILITATING
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING.
THIS MAN SUPPORTERS FROM DAY
ONE HE CONTINUES TO SUPPORT AS-
THE CHANGE INSIDE WERE IN THERE
FOR DAYS OTHER WEEK. LITERALLY
SEEN CULTURE SHIP THE CHANGE IN
THE SHAPING OF A OF A
DEPARTMENT THAT AT ONE TIME
DIDN'T HAVE WE ABILITY TO
PROGRAMS AND I WAS AND- I CAN'T
EXPRESS HOW MUCH. SUPPORT THIS
MAN IS GIVEN THE CHANGE IN A
SHIFT LITERALLY. AS I WATCHED
DAYS GO BY MY STAFF WILL BE UP
SHORTLY TO SPEAK THEIR IN
PRISONS EVERY DAY. OF THE
REALLY WATCHING AS MEN. AND
WOMEN CHANGE HOWDY THINKING
PREPARE TO COME HOME THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. CLOSE
SCOTT BUT NICK FOUNDER OF THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION JUST
ONE TO SPEAK REALLY BRIEFLY IN
SUPPORT OF RALPH HE'S BEEN AN
UNBELIEVABLE PARTNER TO ALL THE
COMMITTEE ORGANIZATIONS WHICH
IS WHY THERE'S FORTY FIVE
PEOPLE WAITING RIGHT NOW.
LEADING CHANGING POLICY IN
LEADING FORMING CARCERI PEOPLE
COME IN A SCRABBLE MESSENGERS.
HE ASKED A BUNCH OF OUR FORMER
LIFERS TO COME IN ACTUALLY
TRAIN IS STAFF SO ARE LIFERS
CAME AND FORMER LIVES IT'S BEEN
DECADES IN PRISON TO TRAIN.
THREE HUNDRED CAPTAINS TO TRAIN
HUNDREDS OF ASSOCIATE WORDS IN
CHIEF DEPUTY WARDENS OPENING UP
THE DOOR. ROUTE HAS AN
UNBELIEVABLE ABILITY. TO NOT
JUST TREAT HIS STAFF AS HUMAN
IN PEOPLE THAT HE CARES ABOUT
BUT TO TREAT THE MEN AND WOMEN
INSIDE AS HUMAN AND PEOPLE THAT
HE CARES ABOUT IT TO BE ABLE TO
STRADDLE BOTH. TO BE ABLE TO.
HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
REHABILITATION IS SOMETHING
THAT IS IT IS AN ART AND WRAPS
AMAZING AT THAT SO. I WANT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND RALPH
THANK YOU FOR WHO YOU ARE.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS OLIVER
MERYL ON WORK WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION I SERVE
TWENTY YEARS. AND A FULL IN
SUPPORT OF MISTER DE AS- I KNOW
THERE'S A DIFFICULT DECISION
THAT ALWAYS MADE BY THE PANELS
TO DECIDE WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN. BUT BECAUSE MISTER DEUS.
PUBLIC SAFETY IS A LOT BETTER.
PEOPLE LIKE US COME OUT AND
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
ACTUALLY BE LOOK AT THE WORLD
AND HAVE PEOPLE LOOK AT US LIKE
HUMAN BEINGS. BECAUSE OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT HE HAS WE HAVE
EDUCATION WE COME OUT COLLEGE
DEGREES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YES SIR HI MY NAME IS
JOHN GROGAN ON THIS STATEWIDE
DIRECTOR PROGRAMS FOR PAUSE FOR
LIFE CANINE RESCUE WE BRING
DOGS INTO THREE CALIFORNIA
PRISONS I WORK IN ALL THREE OF
THOSE A YEAR AGO. I WAS SERVING
SIX LIFE SENTENCES CONSECUTIVE
TO FORTY YEARS A HUNDRED NINETY
TO LIFE AND I WAS THE FIRST TO
ELEVEN SEVENTY DE RECALL
COMMITMENT AT OF THE
SECRETARY'S OFFICE AND I'M NOW
THAT WORKING AT THIS AS A
SERVICE PROVIDER INSIDE THREE
DIFFERENT INSTITUTIONS AND IT'S
BECAUSE OF THE CULTURE THAT
RALPH TIAS HAS SET. WITH INSIDE
INSTITUTIONS WHICH IS REDUCING
VIOLENCE LOWER LOWERING GANG
VIOLENCE REDUCING DRUGS AND
CONTRABAND COMING INTO THE
PRISONS BY HIM ALLOWING THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO COME IN AND DO THEY DO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES SIR. MY
NAME IS A NON FOUNDER CO
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR RESTORE
JUSTICE WHO WERE CLEVERLY IN
THE CRACK COLLABORATIVELY WITH
CDC ON OFFICE VICTIM SERVICES I
WAS A FORMER LIFE FOR SPENT
SIXTEEN YEARS IN PRISON WAS
COMMITTED BY GOVERNOR BROWN AND
SUBSEQUENTLY RELEASED ON
SENATOR FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN.
I'M HERE SUPPORT MISTER DE AS
WHOABOUT FORTY DAYS AFTER I
GOT OUT I GOT AN EMAIL SAYING
THAT HE WOULD LIKE TO MEET WITH
ME ANOTHER COLLEAGUE OF MINE I
DON'T KNOW WHY I FIRST OFF I
RECEIVE I WAS PARTLY SPENT
MULTIPLE YEARS A MAXIMUM
SECURITY PRISONS OF MORE
FREEDOM THAT IS IT AND I WAS IN
THE MASTERS GARY PRISON. BUT
SITTING IN THE SITTING IN A
ROOM AND I'M GONNA SOME OF BY
SAYING MISTER DE AS ASKED ME HE
SAID CAN I GET HELP FROM YOU HE
SAID I NEED. YOUR HELP. IN
MOVING FORWARD. WITH HIS JOB.
PASSED IT ON TO ME AND I WANT
TO. LET EVERYONE HERE THAT.
THANK YOU GRADUATION TO YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS ERIC
ABERCROMBIE. I'M ALSO A MEMBER
RESTORED JUSTICE HUMM FORMALLY
INCARCERATED I JUST WAS
RELEASED AUGUST SEVENTH ABOUT
TWO WEEKS AGO. AND I HAD THE
PLEASURE TO ME ROB DE IS AT.
THE DISTINGUISHED SCHOOL AWARD
IN SAN QUENTIN. AND IT WAS VERY
EVIDENT. THAT HE ACTUALLY
BELIEVE IN A SOUL WASN'T
NECESSARILY ANY DAY NOW YOU SAY
IT. WAS A MATTER WHAT HE SHOWED
US THERE AND NOW WITH THE
SUPPORT WITH YOUR PRESENCE AS
WELL AS THE WORDS FROM YOUR
SPEECH AND EVERYTHING ELSE SO
LIKE I'M HERE TO DEFTLY EXPRESS
MY GRATITUDE. AS WELL AS MY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
YES SIR. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS KURT
STENZEL I AM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION. AND
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF RALPH
I'VE KNOWN ROW FOR ABOUT FIVE
YEARS WE'VE WORKED PRETTY
CLOSELY TOGETHER. RALPH HAS A
AN ABILITY TO PUT PEOPLE AT
EASE. WHEN WE HAVE ISSUES HE IS
OPEN TO DISCUSSION ALONG WITH
THIS STUFF. AND QUITE FRANKLY
THAT MAKES MY JOB A LITTLE
EASIER. I VIEW HIM AS A PROBLEM
SOLVER. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY I
THINK HE IS A MAN THAT CAN MAKE
A DECISION. AND THAT'S THAT'S
PRETTY RARE IN THE WORLD WE
LIVE IN TODAY SPECIAL IN OUR
DEPARTMENT. SO I'D LIKE TO SAY
THANK YOU RALPH FOR ALL YOUR
HELP. AND LOOKING OUT FOR THE
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND MEN AND
WOMEN WHO WORK. THE PRISONS AND
OUR AND OUR STATE TODAY THANK
YOU. YES MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
MOST AUSPICIOUS COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS SUZANNE I GO THERE ARE
MORAL AND I AM A RETIRED
CAPTAIN I'M ALSO THE PRESIDENT
FOR THE REGIONAL AREA OF THE
NOTHING A PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION NATIONAL WINE I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
APPOINTMENT OF ROUGH THE AS I
HAVE THE PLEASURE OF MEETING
AND WORKING WITH PROF IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX I LIKE TO
LOOK AT MY RETIREMENT IS A TYPE
OF PAROLE BECAUSE I'M BACK NOW
IS REPEAT OFFENDER ONLY THIS
TIME ON THE OTHER SIDE WERE
HELPING THE INMATE POPULATION.
THANKS TO THE TYPES OF PROGRAMS
AND THE- MIND SHIFT THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTING AND
THAT IS IN GREAT PART. THANKS
TO THE TYPE OF THINKING OUTSIDE
THE BOX. THINKING GLOBALLY AND
ACTING LOCALLY THIS IS YOUR MAN
HE IS THE EPITOME OF
PROFESSIONALISM AND AGAIN. I
ASK THAT YOU CONFIRM I HOPE I
THINK THAT HE WILL DO THE BEST
JOB. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. VERY
MUCH YES MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS OLGA DURAN AND MY
MOM THE VICE PRESIDENT FOR THE
TO LARRY KING'S HISPANIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. AND I'M
HERE WITH GREAT PLEASURE IN
SUPPORT OF RALPH DE IS JUNIOR.
WE WITH NO DOUBT. SUPPORT RALPH
HE IS OUR VERY OWN FROM OUR
COUNTY OF TULARE. THANK YOU YES
MA'AM. WOULD HAVE TO MOVE THIS
DOWN SORRY AS HELL IT ON DOWN
IT GOES YEAH. THANK YOU WELL IT
GOES A LONG WAY. IT IS EVELYN
GARCIA I AM A PEARL SERVICE
ASSOCIATE AT TOOK AWHILE ABOUT
THE STATE PRISON IMPLY. I AM
ALSO THE ASSOCIATION PRESIDENT
FOR THE CHICANO CORRECTIONAL
WORKERS ASSOCIATION. WHICH IS
C. C. W. A. IS OUR ACRONYM. AND
WE HAVE OVER SIXTEEN HUNDRED
STATE EMPLOYEES BOTHNON AND
NON KEPT. CUSTODY AND NON
BECAUSE HE RETIRED AND ACTIVE
MEMBERS. AND WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF MISTER DE IS AN ALL
THAT HE IS DOING FOR CDC ARE HE
HAS VERY INNOVATIVE IDEAS. THAT
WE WANT TO COLLABORATE AND HELP
WITH HIM AND DO A LOT OF HIS
MENTORING PROGRAMS. WITHIN OUR
OWN ORGANIZATION AS WELL AND WE
ARE IN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND WE DO HOPE THAT.
YOU APPOINT HIM THANK YOU THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JESSICA GUNDERSEN I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIANS PERCEIVED
INJUSTICE I'M GONNA BE BRIEFED
SINCE THERE'S SO MANY FOLKS WE
REPRESENT OVER SIX THOUSAND
CRIME SURVIVORS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. MORE
SURVIVORS THAN ANY NETWORK IN
THE NATION AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT CONFIRMATION OF MISTER
DE AS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING ALONGSIDE HIM THANK
YOU. THANK YOU YES MA'AM GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RUSSIAN
INJURY I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
CONFIRMATION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO A GREAT PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN COUNTY SINCE THE- THANK
YOU THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT AND ARE WE DO WE STILL
HAVE CAN I ASSIST SERGEANTS WE
STOP PEOPLE OUTSIDE. PLEASE
COME ON FOR SIR IF YOU CAN
CHECK AND LET ME KNOW YES SIR.
ALL RIGHT I MADE A BRIEF
STATEMENT HERE I HAVE SOME
SUPPORT FROM CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL SUPERVISORS
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK MONEY
WE ARE REPEAT YOUR NAME FOR OUR
GONZALEZ. YES STAY PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONS
SUPERVISOR ORGANIZATION BETTER
KNOWN AS CCO SO. CCS SO
REPRESENTS FIVE THOUSAND
SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
STATEWIDE WHO WORK IN THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
CORRECTIONS IN REAL DILATATION.
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITAL. WE
ARE OVERWHELMING IN SUPPORT OF
CONFIRMING SECRETARY DEUS OF
THE SECRETARY CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS. THE
START APARTMENT AS A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER. AND IT
WORKED ITS WAY THROUGH MOST OF
THE CORRECTIONAL RANKS TO
EXECUTIVE MANAGEMENT TO BECOME
THE SECRETARY. SIX EXPERIENCE
GIVES HIM A GREATER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE NEEDS OF
STAFF AND INMATES HE OVERSEES
ABOUT A STELLAR CAREER SHOWN
THAT IS FAIR OBJECTIVE
INCENTIVE TO THE NEEDS OF ALL
STAFF AND INMATES. THIS IS A
HIGH IN DEPTH KNOWLEDGE OF
CITIES ARE POLICY THE
PROCEDURES AS WELL AS PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUES AND HAS HAS ON
INSTITUTIONAL SKILLS. MR DO
YEARS HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
DEVELOPING POLICY POSITIVE
CHANGE THE FOCUS ON STAFF WILL
BE. IN A REAL BILL TATIAN AS
WELL AS COMMUNICATION WITH
VICTIMS AND THEIR FAMILIES. OUR
ORGANIZATION CEASAR SO URGES
YOUR VOTE AND CONGRATULATIONS
MISTER DS PRITCHETT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OKAY ARE ALL OF YOU
SPEAKING OR WAS THAT A GROUP.
WE WILL HAVE A BRIEF STATEMENT
LIKE OKAY LET ME AND LET ME
JUST SUGGEST WE NOW I'M NOW
TOLD WE HAVE SIXTY PEOPLE
OUTSIDE SO I'M GOING TO ASK YOU
TO JUST SAY YOUR NAME. THE
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH AND
THAT YOU SUPPORT OUR IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME OKAY MY NAME
IS MATTHEW MCVEIGH AND I KNOW
MISTER DE IS MY ENTIRE CAREER.
I'M THE STATE TREASURER FOR CCS
SO AND ASSOCIATE WARDEN AT KERN
VALLEY STATE PRISON. AND I KNOW
THAT ROB HAS THE FORESIGHT TO
LEAD OUR DEPARTMENT THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU VOTE YES THANK YOU
NAME ORGANIZATION AND MARIA
FAULKNER ACTING ASSOCIATE
WARDEN COUNTRY OPERATIONS KERN
VALLEY STATE PRISON I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF MR RALPH TIAS AS OUR
SECRETARY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS.
QUICK THANK YOU FOURTEEN YEARS
UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP IT'S BEEN
A PLEASURE AS A FEMALE IN THE
DEPARTMENT STARTED OFF AS AN
OFFICER COUNSELOR CAPTAIN AND
NOW ACTING ASSOCIATE WARDEN I
APPRECIATE ALL THE
OPPORTUNITIES HE HAS OFFERED
ME. THANK YOU. YES I AM JANE
AND I'M I'M ACTING CAPTAIN
CRYSTAL BIDDING AT CTS
SOLITAIRE PRISON I AM AND I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF ROSS YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES MA'AM
ACTION IN SOVIET DOMINGUEZ FROM
CHUCKWALLA VALLEY STATE PRISON
OF THE PROCUREMENT OFFICER AND
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT MR DAIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
YES SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MY NAME IS ERIC GODDARD
AND I'M WITH CAL STATE SAN
BERNARDINO WE OPERATE FORTY
REPORTING CENTERS IN THE SOUTH
AND- I'M AND SOME OTHER
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
REPORTING CENTERS. OF PUBLIC
ENTITIES AROUND THE STATE ARE
HERE IN SUPPORT. OF MR DAIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHN
LEVEL. AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY POLICE CHIEFS.
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
NARCOTICS OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
AND THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
PROFESSIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION ALL STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE NOMINATION OF
MISTER DE AS HE IS. UNIQUELY
EXPERIENCED AND QUALIFIED. BY
DINT OF HIS LONG STANDING
EXPERIENCE IN THE AGENCY. AND
HIS HEART ON HIS. HANDS ON.
ABILITIES TO BE. TRULY SOMEONE
WHO EXEMPLIFIES. THE VERY
HIGHEST STANDARDS OF PUBLIC
SERVICE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. YES
SIR NAME ORGANIZATION IF YOU'RE
WITH ONE AND YOUR POSITION MY
NAME'S EUGENE DAY WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF FOR OFF THE
AS FOR SECRETARY OF
CORRECTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GLADDEN RECIDIVISM COALITION AM
SUPPORT THANK YOU. A PROGRESS
IN ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH YES
MA'AM HI RILEY PRESLEY I'M HERE
WITH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND I'M FOR ME
INCARCERATED AND I'M HERE FOR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH YES
SIR. HELLO MY NAME IS JACOB OF
ART ON WITH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION ALSO KNOWN AS A R. C.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT ROUTE
D. IS CONFIRMATION I'M A FORMER
LIFE FOR. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YES SIR HI MY NAME IS GERRY KEY
THEM OF FORMALLY INCARCERATED
LIVE FOR AND I'M NOW WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION ALSO KNOWN
AS A OR C. AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT ROUGH TIAS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. YES SIR. MY NAME IS
SUSAN AGO I'M PART OF A OR C.
HOPE COMPLEXION TEAM I AM A
FORMER LIFE AND I AM FULL
SUPPORT OF REFUSE. THANK YOU.
YES SIR. MY NAME IS CARLOS THE
SENATE FROM PART OF ARC IN THE
HOPE OF REDEMPTION TEAM. AT THE
TWENTY ONE YEARS IN A ROOM FULL
SUPPORT AROUND DS BECAUSE HE
BELIEVES REHABILITATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU YES SIR. HELLO
MY NAME IS MATTHEW GOING DOWN
PART OF THE ART TEAM AS WELL
OPEN RETENTION TEAM I DID
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AS A LIFER
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT RALPH
THE AS AS WELL SO. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. YES
SIR. HELLO MY NAME IS EYES
THEIR JORDAN I'M A PART OF THE
A. R. C. T. AND I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT. OF ROE VS AND I AM
WHAT I HAVE DONE SIX YEARS
FORMERLY INCARCERATED. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH YES MA'AM.
ASIA CANS ALONE HERE TO SUPPORT
ROUTE THE IS FORMAL CASTRATING
YEARS AND I'M HERE FROM A. R.
C. THANK YOU SO MUCH YES SIR
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ALVIN
KIMBRELL I AND FORMALLY
INCARCERATED AT SIR TWENTY
THREE YEARS THREE MONTHS IN
TWENTY THREE DAYS IF THIS WAS
SCOTT CURRENT ID HERE AS WELL
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT RAFI S.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YES SIR. A GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY GO PART OF THEIR
SEATS OPEN POSITION TEAM I'M
ALSO A FORMER LIFE AND IT'S AN
HONOR AND PLEASURE TO BE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF ROUGH TIAS. THANK
YOU. YES AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
COREY PEPPER I AM WITH AND THEN
COALITION I'M A FORMER LIFE IN
ME AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF ROUGH
DAIS THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
MY NAME IS TOM TO LUNA I AM
WITH A. R. C. FORMERLY
INCARCERATED AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT PRACTICE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH YES MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON
DANIEL SANCHEZ WITH THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA HERE IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SECRETARIES.
APPOINTMENT I JUST WANT TO
THANK HIM FOR HIS COORDINATION
OVER THE YEARS AND WE CONTINUE
TO WORK VERY CLOSELY ON
CONTINUITY OF REHABILITATIVE
AND RE ENTRY SERVICES SO LOOK
FOR TO THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THAT YES MA'AM. GOOD
AFTERNOON MANAGER MEMBERS WHO
SHOP MUCH LIKE HIM WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNMENT'S AT GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT OF SECTOR DHEAS TO
CDC ARE. NOW WE ALSO HAVE
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH HIM
OVER THE YEARS. IN NEW GARCIA
VERY INTO COULD PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUES THAT AFFECT THE
CALIFORNIA'S. CORRECTIONAL
SYSTEM AND WE- LOOKING FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THEM AT IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU SO MUCH YES SIR. HI MY NAME
IS HANDLED THROUGH FROM THE CO
FOUNDER OF SELF AWARENESS AND
RECOVERY. AND ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
AND INFORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUAL. I'M IN SUPPORT OF
MR RALPH TIAS AND YOU KNOW
BASED ON A SUPPORT HE SAID HAD
WITH A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE FAMILIES.
OF AND REPRESENTING THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
ALSO WE ARE PRO THAT YOU'RE
LETTING THE WE FINALLY GOT A
PERSON OF COLOR THERE. SO
THAT'S ONE OF THE BIG MAIN
REASON WHY SUPPORTS MY MATH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH YES
MA'AM. HELLO I'M CRISTINA
ROBINSON AND I'M ALSO WITH SELF
AWARENESS AND RECOVERY AND I AM
DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT OF ROUGH
IDEAS THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH YES SIR. MY NAME IS
THE SEAN MORRIS AND I'M A
SUPPORTER RAFI AS WELL I WAS A
LIGHT FROM WITHIN WHEN I WAS
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD PRESIDENT
CAME HOME IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN. AND I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BETTER MYSELF.
WHY HE WAS AWARDED FACT ALLOW
CERTAIN PROGRAMS THE COMING TO
THE PRISON AND I THINK THAT
HE'S GOING TO BE EXCELLENT AND
I'M PRAYING TO GOD. THAT HE
TAKES THAT EXCELLENT AND TURN
INTO A MIRACLE IN HELPING TO
BETTER RE ENTRY PROGRAM SELF
HELP PROGRAMS BECAUSE WE
DEFINITELY NEED IT WHICH MEANS
YOU HAVE A SAFER COMMUNITY AS
GUYS COME HOME. AND YOU GAVE ME
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO HELP BETTER
MYSELF SO I'M A SUPPORTER
OBVIOUS. AND I'M WITH A A. R.
C. ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
YES MA'AM. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ELLEN GOLDWASSER AND
I'M WITH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
ROUGH IDEAS AND THEN MENTAL
HEALTH THERAPIST AT THE
INTEREST OF THEM COLLECTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. OKAY NO NO
OTHER NO OTHER PERSON IN
SUPPORT OKAY. LET ME MOVE TO
THOSE IN OPPOSITION. I'D LIKE
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE I KNOW TIME IS SHORT
SO I'M GOING TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE A COUPLE OF OTHER PEOPLE
WOMEN WHO ARE HERE IN. IN
OPPOSITION IN A CERTAIN WAY SO
I WILL DO THIS AS QUICKLY AS I
CAN IT LET ME JUST SAY ARE YOU
ARE YOU PART OF THE COMPLAINT
IT A COMPLAINT AND- YES BUT
THAT'S I'M SPEECH I UNDERSTAND
I UNDERSTAND. IN FAIRNESS YOU
HAD REQUESTED FOR MINUTES MOST
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE COME
IN IN A MINUTE SO YOU'RE GOING
TO GET TWO MINUTES AS WE
TYPICALLY ALLOW EVERYONE I
SHORTENED OTHERS. I AM ABLE
FOLLOW THAT RULE SOME PEOPLE
DID NOT BUT WE WERE UNDER. A
MINUTE FOR MOST PEOPLE I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT THAT'S WHY
I'M ASKING TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE OTHER TWO PEOPLE SO THAT
YOU'RE NOT GIVING EACH OF THEM
TO ICING COVER. I WILL BE LESS
THAN THE TOTAL OF SIX MINUTES
BY FAR I WILL I WILL AGREE WITH
THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH I DID
NOT UNDERSTAND THANK YOU AND I
DON'T FORGET TO GIVE ME YOUR
NAME. I WILL. SO MY NAME IS
LESLIE LEVY I'VE BEEN A CIVIL
RIGHTS ATTORNEY FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS. AT THE MOMENT I
REPRESENT TWO VERY COURAGEOUS
WOMEN OF TAKEN THE STEP OF
CHALLENGING. THE SYSTEMIC
GENDER. DISCRIMINATION IN CD C.
R. WHICH THEY HAVE ENCOUNTERED
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEAR HISTORY
IS WITH THE DEPARTMENT. THIS
TESTIMONY IS NOT ABOUT THAT
LAWSUIT. I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE WOMEN IN C. D. C. R. WHO
WILL NOT PUBLICLY TESTIFY. AT
BECAUSE OF THEIR REALISTIC FEAR
OF RETALIATION AND IF YOU
NOTICED OUT OF THE SIXTY OR SO
PEOPLE WHO JUST TESTIFIED.
THERE WERE ONLY THREE WOMEN
PEACE OFFICERS WHO STEP
FORWARD. AND I THINK THAT'S
REFLECTIVE OF THE FEAR THE
WOMEN HAVE IN THE SYSTEM. YOU
HAVE MY COVER LETTER YOU HAVE
THE LETTER WRITTEN BY SPECIAL
AGENT IN CHARGE PARKER I'M NOT
GOING TO GO OVER THAT IN ANY
DETAIL. WHAT I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT IS THAT MISTER DE AS HAS
COME BEFORE YOU WHEN EXPLAINED
IN RESPONSE TO A QUESTION WHAT
THE PROCESSES IN TERMS OF IO
COMPLAINTS SIX CETERA. YET NONE
THE LESS TWO AND A HALF YEARS
AGO WHEN HE WAS EXPLICITLY
GIVEN. INFORMATION ABOUT THE
LEVEL DATA. ABOUT AS HE SAID
DATA DRIVEN INFORMATION ABOUT
THE LEVEL OF DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST WOMEN IN C. D. C. R.
NOT ONLY DID HE NOT DO ANYTHING
TO ADDRESS IT HE DIDN'T EVEN
FOLLOW. THE VERY PROCEDURES SET
FORTH IN THIS. BUT THAT HE HAS
SET FORTH HERE TODAY HE NEVER
REPORTED IT TO THE OEO OFFICE
HE NEVER REPORTED IT TO THE
OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS. THE
OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS RIGHT
NOW IS WITHIN THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL. AFFAIRS AND LET ME
TELL YOU THAT THEIR STATISTICS
ARE SUCH THAT. OUT OF A HUNDRED
AND SIXTEEN SPECIAL AGENTS
NINETEEN ARE WOMEN. THERE ARE
NO SPECIAL AGENTS IN CHARGE IN
THE OFFICE OF INVESTIGATIVE
AFFAIRS WHICH. OVERSEAS THE
OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS THAT
SHOULD TELL YOU SOMETHING. IN
THE OFFICE OF THE CORRECTIONAL
SAFETY. THERE ARE A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE PEACE OFFICERS SIX
OF THEM ARE WOMEN. TWO OF THEM
ARE SUPERVISORS THAT IS IT AND
THOSE NUMBERS ARE GOING DOWN
QUICKLY NOT UP. THE PERCENTAGE
OF PEACE OFFICERS AND CDC ARE
IS 17% BASED ON THEIR OWN
STATISTICS AND 5275% OF FEMALE
PEACE OFFICERS ARE SUBJECTED TO
SEXUAL HARASSMENT WOMEN ARE
PASSED OVER FOR PROMOTION THERE
CHASED OUT FOR DISCRIMINATORY
ATTITUDES THEY'RE DENIED
ADVANCEMENT AND LIVE WITH
REALISTIC FEAR OF RETALIATION.
THERE ARE CLEAR BENEFITS TO THE
MISSION OF CDC ARE IN THE
TAXPAYERS OF THE STATE TO HAVE
GENDER EQUITY AS THE NUMBER OF
WOMEN IN THE DEPARTMENT IF THE
NUMBER OF WOMEN IN THE
DEPARTMENT WERE TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE. THE
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THERE ARE
FEWER HARASSMENT DISCRIMINATION
AND RETALIATION CASES WHICH TO
DATE HAVE COST THE STATE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. FURTHER
AND MANY MANY STUDIES INCLUDING
SOME OUT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE SHOW THAT IS THE NUMBER
OF FEMALE PEACE OFFICER RISE
THE NUMBER OF EXCESSIVE FORCE
LAWSUIT TO DROP DRAMATICALLY
AGAIN SAVING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. AND RESULTING IN MORE
HUMANE TREATMENT OF THOSE WHO
ARE SUBJECTED TO ARREST AND
IMPRISONMENT. TO APPROVE MISTER
DEALS AT THIS POINT MOMENT IN
TIME ESPECIALLY AFTER WHAT IS
PRESENTED HERE AS HIS PROCESS
FOR DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE HE
MENTIONED. GAR WHICH IS THE
GOVERNMENT ALLIANCE FOR RAGE
RACIAL RACE AND EQUITY WHICH IS
A VERY IMPORTANT ORGANIZATION.
IT DOES NOT ADDRESS GENDER. HE
HAS GIVEN YOU NOTHING NOTHING
IN THIS HEARING THAT SHOWS THAT
HE IS IN ANY WAY ADDRESSING
GENDER IN HIS GENDER
DISCRIMINATION IN THIS
DEPARTMENT DESPITE HAVING
EXPLICIT KNOWLEDGE OF THE
PROBLEM FOR TWO AND A HALF
YEARS AND A DAD AND AS YOU CAN
SEE FROM THE NUMBERS I'VE GIVEN
YOU CLEARLY DATA DRIVEN. THE.
TO WE ARE HERE WITH WELL LET ME
ALSO JUST SAY THERE ARE LOTS OF
RESOURCES OUT THERE AROUND THE
GENDER ISSUES. THE ASSOCIATION
OF WOMEN EXECUTIVES IN
CORRECTION. I DON'T SEE ANY
INVOLVEMENT WITH CDC ARE WITH
THAT THEY'VE NOT UNTIL THIS
YEAR SENT ANY WOMEN TO ANY
CONFERENCES THAT HAVE TO DO
WITH CORRECTIONS ARE MOVING UP
THEY ARE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. HAS TONS OF
INFORMATION FOR THEM THE FBI
HAS BETTER STATISTICS ABOUT
WOMEN AGENTS THAN CDC ARE DOES.
THAT SOUND. AS. MISTER DIAZ
SAID THAT YOU KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT CAN DO BETTER ON WHO
THEY HIRE I THINK THAT JUST
SENDING MISTER DE AS IS A
NOMINATION ON TO THE SENATE
FLOOR MEANS THAT THIS COMMITTEE
IS NOT DOING BETTER THAN A CAT
SO WE ARE HERE WITH TO ASKS.
ONE IS THAT THIS COMMITTEE
USAGE STATUTORY AUTHORITY UNDER
PENAL CODE SECTION SIX ONE TWO
SIX WHICH SPECIFICALLY ALLOWS
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE TO
ORDER THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL. TO DO AN
INVESTIGATION ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THERE IS SYSTEMIC
DISCRIMINATION ABOUT WOMEN IN
CDC ARE. EVEN WITH THIS
SUGGESTION THERE'S A CABBIE OP
BECAUSE MANY OF THE PEOPLE IN
THE OFFICE OF. NO Y. G. R.
FRIENDS WITH THE OFF PEOPLE AND
I A SO IT WOULD HAVE TO BE A
CAREFULLY CHOSEN GROUP. WHO IS
NOT CONNECTED WITH THE. I CAN
ASK THE SECOND HALF IS THAT
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE CONFIRMS
ANYONE. FOR THE LEADERSHIP OF
CDC ARE THAT THIS COMMITTEE
REQUIRE THE CANDIDATE TO
PRESENT TO YOU. A VERY SPECIFIC
AND FUNDED PLAN TO INCREASE THE
RECRUITMENT HIRING PROMOTION
AND RETENTION OF. WOMEN IN THE
DEPARTMENT AND I CLOSE WITH.
JUST THIS. I THINK THAT I WOULD
I'M JUST MY CLOSING SENTENCE I
WONDER I DO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS MATTER
ALTHOUGH I DIDN'T HEAR MUCH IN
THE WAY OF QUESTIONS OF MISTER
DE AS ABOUT THIS ISSUE WHICH I
THINK IS CRITICAL AND I HOPE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WILL TAKE VERY
SERIOUSLY THE TO ASKS THAT WE
HAVE BECAUSE IT IS WHAT WILL
SUPPORT THE WOMEN IN THE
DEPARTMENT AND CDC ARE WHO RISK
THEIR LIVES EVERY SINGLE DAY.
TO KEEP THIS DEPARTMENT GOING
AND ARE DENIED THEIR PROMOTIONS
AND SUPPORT IN THE DEPARTMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU LET ME
RESPOND ON ONE IN TERMS OF OUR-
REFERRING. TO THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL I WOULD SAY. I'M NOT
PREPARED TO RESPOND TO THAT
QUESTION TODAY HOWEVER I HEAR
YOUR REQUEST I'M GOING TO REFER
THAT. TO OUR SECRETARY AND WE
WILL RESPOND TO THAT I WILL
RESPOND TO THAT. IS GENERALLY
AND SECONDARILY I WOULD SAY. I
THINK I THINK ARE SENATE ARE AS
A WHOLE AND I THINK THE RULES
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ON.
THOROUGHLY HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH A NUMBER OF PEOPLE ABOUT
OUR LEVEL OF EXPECTATION. I
THINK WE AS I STATED EARLIER.
WE DO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY WE'VE
HAD TO FACE OURSELVES AND OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS HAVE HAD TO
MAKE MAJOR CHANGES IN THE WAY
THAT WE CONDUCT BUSINESS. AND
IT WOULD BE REALLY. WRONG OF US
NOT TO HOLD YOU TO THAT
EXPECTATION AND THE INSTITUTION.
A CDC ARE AND I THINK WE HAVE
THAT EXPECTATION AND I THINK
THAT WE ALSO HAVE THE ABILITY
THROUGH POLICY COMMITTEES
THROUGH OUR BUDGET PROCESS AND
THROUGH THE COMMITMENT I HAVE
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION. THAT WE
WILL HAVE CONTINUE CONVERSATION
SO WE CAN ACTUALLY ACTUALLY
MEASURE SUCCESS. BECAUSE OUR AS
I SAID IN MY COMMENTS WE HAVE
GOALS AND ASPIRATIONS AND
VALUES BUT IT IS UP TO US TO
MAKE IT REAL. I AND WE ARE
PAINFULLY AWARE IN THIS
COMMITTEE WHAT IT TAKES TO DO
THAT HOUR UPON HOUR UPON HOUR.
OF COMMITTEES TO PUT TOGETHER A
NEW PROCESS FOR INVESTIGATIONS
I. AM COMPELLED PERSONALLY I
WASN'T SURE WHO WOULD SHOW UP
TODAY TO SPEAK IT I AM NOT
UNFAMILIAR WITH PEOPLE WHO SHOW
UP TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE HAD SOME
CONTENTIOUS HEARINGS IN THE
PAST ARE WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO HEAR PEOPLE
ARE SPEAKING AND I THINK WE
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY AND I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES WHO TOOK
THE TIME TO MEET. OUR WITH THE
OPPOSITION. AHA AND TO HEAR IT
OUT AND WE WILL TAKE THOSE WE
WILL TAKE THOSE COMMENTS I
THINK THE HARD. TODAY ARE I
WILL SAY I'M ALSO IMPRESSED BY
THE PEOPLE WHO SPOKE IN
OPPOSITION WHO ACTUALLY HAVE
COME OUT OF. CDC ARE ARE A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO. DID I SAY
OPPOSITION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. I IT PARTICULARLY A. R. C.
AND A NUMBER OF THE FORMER
INCARCERATED WHO FEEL COMPELLED
TO COME HERE AND SPEAK AND SAY.
HOW THEY WERE BENEFITTED THAT
IS OUR GOAL THAT IS OUR HOPE
AND I'M PRETTY SURE THERE ARE
MANY MORE OUT THERE. THAT WE
HOPE WILL AVAIL THEMSELVES OF
THAT TODAY I. APPRECIATE
EVERYONE WHO CAME I KNOW IT IS
YOUR TOM AND WE HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO LISTEN AND TO
TAKE THESE ISSUES TO HEART. AND
I THINK WE ARE WHETHER YOU
WITNESS THAT TODAY I WE HAVE
SEEN THE APPOINTMENT SCHEDULE
IN ADVANCE AND WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING. TOWARDS A HEARING THAT
TAKES ALL THESE ISSUES INTO
ACCOUNT. I A I WILL BE SUPPORT
OF TODAY. BECAUSE I'VE HAD
THESE CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU I
THINK YOU KNOW VERY WELL. YOU
HAVE THE BURDEN OF BEING THE
LEADER. THAT IS A HEAVY BURDEN.
ASA I'M NOT SURE I WOULD WANT
YOUR BURDEN BUT. I'M GLAD THAT
SOMEONE DOES WE HAVE THE
LARGEST PRISON SYSTEM IN THE
WORLD. AND IT IS GOING TO BE NO
SMALL TASK TO CHANGE CULTURE.
WHETHER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
CULTURE OF OUR MANAGEMENT THE
INSTITUTION OR THE GUARDS. AND
THAT WILL BE YOUR HIGHEST
CHARGE. AND I HAVE EVERY
INTENTION TO USE MY ROLE TO
HOLD YOU ACCOUNTABLE TODAY I
INTEND TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S. A APPOINTMENT AND
RECOMMENDATION AND WOOD I
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. I
UNDERSTOOD THAT WAS ALL THE
OPPOSITION. MORE OPPOSITION I
AND I THOUGHT I UNDERSTOOD THAT.
SENATOR MINING. THANK YOU MADAM
PRO TEM NINE I JUST WANT TO
ECHO SOME OF. YOUR COMMENTS ANA
IN KNOWLEDGE ALL THOSE WHO ARE
HERE TODAY I DID HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND I THINK IN YOUR
CLOSING COMMENTS MADAM PRO TEM.
THERE HAS BEEN A RECOGNITION
TODAY IS NOT A ONE AND DONE I
ALSO DID HEAR THE CANDIDATE
MISTER DE IS IN RESPONSE TO MY
QUESTION. EIGHT KNOWLEDGE AND
COMMIT MOVING FORWARD TO.
LOOKING AT DIVERSITY IN GENDER
EQUITY IN RECRUITMENT IN
RETENTION AND IN PROMOTION. IN
THAT COMMITMENT MADE HERE TODAY.
IS A COMMITMENT THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER ON TO
SEE HOW THAT IS. IMPLEMENTED IN
MOVES FORWARD IT IS AN AT
PLEASURE APPOINTMENT IN WE IN
THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH TO HAVE
A DUTY OF CONTINUE TO OVERSIGHT
ONE OF THE TOOLS AVAILABLE TO
US THROUGH PENAL CODE SECTION
SIXTY ONE TWENTY SIX WOULD BE
TO SEEK. AN OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL INVESTIGATION I THINK
THE PRO TEM HAS ATTRACTED STAFF
THROUGH OUR SECRETARY TO
EXPLORE THAT POSSIBILITY BUT I
THINK AGAIN TODAY'S NOT THE DAY
TO MAKE A COMMITMENT OF THAT
NATURE I THINK THE COMMITMENT
TODAY IS TO WORK TOGETHER
TOWARD SHARED IN COMMON
OBJECTIVES. AGAIN AS THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH IT IS NOT
OUR ROLE TO DIG INTO SUBJECT
MATTER THAT IS THE CURRENT
SUBJECT OF LITIGATION OUR
JUDICIAL BRANCH. IS OVERSEEING
THAT. I WOULD SUBMIT THAT THE
COMPLAINANTS ARE WELL
REPRESENTED IN WILL HAVE THEIR
DAY IN COURT ON IN HIM
ENCOURAGED TO HEAR THAT THERE
MAY BE A MEDIATION PROCESS.
LOOKING FORWARD AND WOULD HOPE
THAT WOULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE PARTIES TO FURTHER LOOK
NOT ONLY TO THE NATURE OF
CURRENT COMPLAINTS BUT TO A
PROCESS OF MOVING FORWARD. BY I
DO WANT TO THANK THE CANDIDATE
FOR. HIS CANDOR AND IN PERHAPS
MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR HIS YEARS
OF SERVICE AND I THINK BY HIS
OWN AND KNOWLEDGE MINT IN IN
MISSION THIS IS A HUGE
BUREAUCRACY. NOT WITHOUT ITS
FAULTS AND DEFECTS IN THE ONLY
WAY WE ACHIEVE THE SYSTEM WE
WANT THAT CAN CONTINUE. TO
RESULT. IN FOR SOME EARLY
RELEASE AND ZERO RECIDIVISM
SOME OF THESE CITIZENS WHO
TESTIFIED TODAY WE NEED TO
ASPIRE TO MAKE THE CALIFORNIA
PRISON SYSTEM A MODEL NOT JUST
IN THIS NATION BUT
INTERNATIONALLY IN IN TALKING.
WITH THE CANDIDATE I KNOW
THERE'S SOME INTERNATIONAL
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS THAT
HE'S STUDYING WERE UNIQUE
NATION WHERE UNIQUE STATE BUT
WHERE WE CAN LEARN FROM THE
SUCCESSES OF OTHERS I HEARD AN
OPEN MIND THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL THAT WE'RE
GONNA. ADAPT AND GROW THIS
SYSTEM TO HOPEFULLY REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF INMATES REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF RESOURCES AND SUCCEED
IN BUILDING A HIGHER LEVEL OF
SUCCESSFUL REHABILITATION IN
LOWER RECIDIVISM SO. KIND OF A
LONG PATHWAY TO A MOTION IN
SUPPORT OF THIS NOMINATION.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU LET ME
JUST RECONFIRM THAT YOU SAID IN
YOUR VERY EARLY RESPONSES TO
QUESTIONS BUT SENATOR MINING
JUST REPEATED THE COMMITMENT
AND I JUST WANNA FOR THE
RECORD. YOU HEAR YOUR RESPONSE
THE COMMITMENT AS IT RELATES I
AM FULLY COMMITTED THANK YOU TO
THESE TO THESE ISSUES TO MAKE
IN THIS THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY
WITHIN CORRECTIONS BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT I MUST HAVE AN
EQUITABLE AND A WELL BALANCED
AND A- GENDER SPECIFIC WORKING
GROUP AND IN FLOOR AND DEMAND
THAT WE DO BETTER AND THAT WE
HAVE PROCESSES IN PLACE. TO
WHAT WE ARE HIRING ACROSS LINES
AND TO RECOGNIZE THAT YOU KNOW
THAT IMPLICIT BIAS DOES EXIST
AND THEN WE HAVE TO TRAIN OUR
STAFF AND EXECUTIVES TO SEE
THAT AND HIGHER. THE CORRECT
WORKFORCE. THANK YOU. MADAM
SECRETARY AND THANK YOU SENATOR
OFF I'M SORRY SENATOR ROTH MAKE
A BRIEF YES YES PLEASE YOU KNOW
MISTER SECRETARY. FIVE FIRM.
MADE TO YOUR APPOINTING
AUTHORITY AWARE OF SOME ISSUES
WITH REGARD TO THE INTERNAL
COMPLAINT AN INVESTIGATION
PROCESS IN YOUR DEPARTMENT
APPARENT ISSUES. BUT I EXPECT
TO BE ADDRESSED AND IF THOSE
AREN'T MADE KNOWN TO YOU AT
SOME POINT TIME I WOULD ASK
THAT YOU LET ME KNOW AND I WILL
MAKE THOSE KNOWN TO USE A
DIFFICULT IN ON. AND THOSE
ADDITIONAL ISSUES THAT
IDENTIFIED ARE BASED ON THE
FACT THAT I HAVE DONE THIS TYPE
OF WORK FOR FORTY FIVE YEARS.
AND I HAVE SOME CONCERNS AND I
EXPECT THOSE TO BE ADDRESSED
AND IN THE FUTURE IF THEY ARE
NOT. WE MAY HAVE A DIFFERENT
KIND OF CONVERSATION. OKAY YES
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU SENATOR SENATOR BATES
YEAH FOR HONESTY OF WHEN WE HAD
OUR CONVERSATION AND AGAIN HERE
I EXPRESSED ON THAT I WAS GOING
TO I GUESS LAY OFF AS YOU WOULD
SAY. UNTIL WE HAD MORE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT THE
THING THAT THAT I'M MOST
CONCERNED WITH ENOUGH THAT
THERE'S SOME SORT OF TRACKING
AND THERE'S A PLAN AND THERE'S
A TRACKING UP THAT ON THOSE TWO
ISSUES SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
RESPONSES COMPLAINTS ON HOW THE
RESEARCH DEAL WITH AND
CERTAINLY THIS GENDER.
DISCRIMINATION ISSUE WHICH IS
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE MAJOR
PRIORITY AND FOCUS TODAY. BUT
HAVING BEEN A SOCIAL WORKER
HAVING DEAL WITH PEOPLE THAT
FOUND THEIR WAY UNFORTUNATELY
INTO. YOUR OUR AGENCY I THINK
THAT THE TOUGH MONEY TODAY IS
OVERWHELMING IN TERMS OF WHAT
YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO. HOW
YOUR VIEW JOB BY THOSE YOU WORK
WITH AND HOW YOU'RE VIEWED BY
THOSE THAT YOU MUST STOP. YOU
KNOW A BOMB. I GUESS. PLEASE
PUT THE PUNISHMENT ON IN AND
THE DISCIPLINE ON SO I'M
CHANGING MY- OPINION RIGHT
HERE. BUT YEAR COMMITMENT TO
THE ACCOUNTABILITY THAT EACH
ONE OF US OF ASK FOR. IS ALL
FIRST AND FOREMOST IN MY MIND
THAT THAT WILL BE SOMETHING
TANGIBLE WITH DAN. YOU KNOW I
WOULD SAY BY THE FIRST OF THE
YEAR WHEN YEAR. WE'RE POINTING
AND FIND. I'M ASSUMING IT'S
GOING TO BE CONFIRMED ON THE
FLOOR. WHEN YOU WILL BE
ACTUALLY INSTALLED OFFICIALLY
AGAIN. HI AND WE WOULD HOLD BY
THAT TIME YOU HAVE TO US SAW
THAT PLAN HOW YOU TRACKING IT
BEYOND HOPEFULLY. I THINK THAT
IS ACTUALLY REDUCING THE
COMPLAINTS OF THAT THEY'RE
BEING DEALT WITH AND I THINK
THE RECIDIVISM ISSUE. IS HUGE
AND I THINK THIS ENTIRE STATE.
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AND
WE WANT TO SEE PEOPLE SAFE IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES SO THAT
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T READY TO BE
RELEASED. ARE CERTAINLY ON THE
EXTENDED IN THEIR TIME IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO CHANGE BEHAVIOR
AND OB. RE ENTER OUR COMMUNITY
AS PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS BUT BOB.
I THINK YOUR RESUME AND WHAT WE
HEARD HERE TODAY AND YOUR
COMMITMENT KNOWING THAT YOU
HAVE A FEW. LITTLE FLAWS ALONG
THE WAY ARE GOING TO BE
ADDRESSED IN IN A TIMELY MANNER
IN A SHORT. TIME SO I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT IT TODAY AND MAYBE
BETWEEN NOW AND WHEN IT'S ON
THE FLOOR WE CAN HAVE ANOTHER
CONVERSATION. ABOUT YOUR
PROCESS BUT AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS AND- I DON'T
KNOW YOU STAND OUT TRULY STAND
OUT ANY AND ALL THE TERMS OF
THE CORRECTION SYSTEM. ALL OF
THE PAST AND AS WE GO FORWARD
WITH RESTORATIVE JUSTICE. SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL OF YOU WHO CAME
FORWARD AND- KIND OF SHARED
YOUR PERSONAL STORIES ANY AND
CERTAINLY REVEALED. BECAUSE
SOME OF THE ALL THE LIFE PATH
THAT TO KEEP THE WRONG A AND HE
WAS ABLE TO. ABOUT HIT THE FORK
IN THE ROAD. THE RIGHT WAY. I
ATKINS I CAN SIGN IT IS
UNANIMOUS CONGRATULATIONS THANK
YOU
. THANK YOU ANNA AND THANK
YOU FOR EXISTING QUIETLY WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK AS I
INVITE MISS OSBORNE UP I'M
GOING TO ASK OUR SECRETARY IF
SHE WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATOR BATES.
BATES HI IT'S FIVE ZERO FIVE
ZERO ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AND THEN ON ITEM TWO J. WHICH
IS GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE IS NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR ITEM TWO J.
OPEN THE ROLE. SENATOR BATES.
BATES NO THAT'S FOR ONE THAT IS
FOR ONE THAT APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
FIVE MINUTE BREAK AND BE RIGHT
BACK
. WE HAVE A QUORUM SO I'M
GONNA. RECONVENE. ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES ARE HERE MISS
OSBORNE LET ME INVITE YOU
FORWARD. THIS IS MISS OSBORNE
IS THE APPOINTEE FOR THE
DIRECTOR DIVISION OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
WELCOME. AND I WILL INVITE YOU
TO GIVE YOUR OPENING COMMENTS
AND ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE YOU
WOULD LIKE TO THAT HERE WITH
YOU PERSONALLY WILL GO RIGHT
INTO COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
WELCOME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AMOUNT OF TIME AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE HONOR TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY. OKAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHARM AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE HONOR TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU
TODAY MY NAME IS JENNIFER
OSBORN AND I HAD THE HONOR TO
BE SUPPORTED BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOME AND MY APPOINTMENT AS
DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES AT CDC
ARE. MY HUSBAND IS FEARFUL WHO
IS THAT A FEW COLLEAGUES FROM
FORMER. AGENCIES ARE
HISTORICALLY. I GREW UP IN
RURAL SENATOR COUNTY AND MY
FATHER WAS A CITY FIREFIGHTER
FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS MY MOTHER
WORKED PART TIME AS A LIBRARIAN
WHILE RAISING FOUR CHILDREN.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN PASSIONATE
ABOUT PUBLIC SERVICE I BEGAN MY
STATE CAREER AS A BUDGET
ANALYST AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT. WHICH IS WHERE MY
HUSBAND PHILIP WORKS NOW. IN
EARLY TWENTY TWELVE IT MOVED TO
THE STATE AND CONSUMER SERVICES
AGENCIES WORK AS THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR FISCAL
OPERATIONS. THIS WAS A TIME OF
GREAT CHANGE BECAUSE A SWEEPING
REORGANIZATION PLAN THAT WOULD
ELIMINATE TO STATE AGENCIES AND
STAND UP THREE NEW ONES THAT
JUST BEEN ANNOUNCED. ONE OF THE
AGENCIES THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY WOULD LARGELY
INFLUENCED MY POTS OF THIS
POSITION. I SPENT ALMOST FIVE
YEARS AGO OF OPS AND WAS
FORTUNATE TO LEARN FROM AND
SERVE UNDER SECRETARY. MERRILL
DEVELOP AFTER. AMONG OTHER
THINGS. ENCOURAGE MY PASSION
FOR SOLVING ADMINISTRATIVE AND
BUREAUCRATIC PROBLEMS TO ALWAYS
TRY TO FIND A WAY TO GET CS. I
CONSIDER CDC ARE TO BE A
CHALLENGE AND AN OPPORTUNITY TO
USE MY EXPERIENCE IN A WAY.
THAT HELPS THE DEPARTMENT'S
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESSES.
IMPROVE THE DEPARTMENT'S
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESSES AND
MAKES WAY FOR ITS PROGRAMS TO
OPERATE SEAMLESSLY. A STRAIGHT
OF SERVICES UNDER MY PURVIEW
PROVIDE CRITICAL SUPPORTS ALL
OF CCAR'S PROGRAMS INCLUDING
THOSE PROVIDING TRAINING
AFFECTS AND DISCIPLINE. TO
ASSIST THE STATE DEPARTMENT AND
THESE DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANTS
IN FURTHERANCE OF THE GOALS OF
THE ADMINISTRATION. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATE ROTH LET ME START WITH
YOU THIS ROUND THANK YOU MAYOR
PRO TEM ACTUALLY I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS. CONGRATULATIONS VERY
IMPRESSIVE RESUME. AND IF ANY
PORTION OF OUR- ABSOLUTELY
SUPERB GOV UP SECRETARIES
REVVED UP ON YOU YOU'RE THE
GOLD STANDARD SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO MOVING YOUR CONFIRMATION AN
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATOR MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN. CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR APPOINTMENT I DON'T I
DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS EITHER
I MEAN WE MET YESTERDAY HAD A
LOVELY CONVERSATION AND
CERTAINLY VERY WELL QUALIFIED
FOR THE JOB AND I KNOW YOU'RE-
EXCITED TO GET GOING. THEY GET
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES. IS
AWESOME ARE NOT CONGRADULATIONS
ON YOUR APPOINTMENT AND WE
DIDN'T HAVE A HARD TIME
YESTERDAY WHEN YOU WERE IN MY
OFFICE WE SPENT MOST OF OUR
TIME TALKING TO OF MY TIME
TALKING WITH MISTER DIAZ OF BUT
TIE YOUR CERTAINLY ARE.
INCREDIBLY QUALIFIED FOR THE
JOB I JUST WANT TO HEAR FROM
YOU HOW YOU TRACK THE ARE THE
CONTRACTS VENDOR CONTRACTS FOR
THE REHABILITATION SINCE
THOUSAND YOU KNOW BIG FOCUS AND
ENSURING THAT ARE THEY ARE
DELIVERING ARE THE KIND OF
FOLLOW SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
THAT ARE YOU KNOW I'M MEETING
OUT THESE ARE I THINK GREAT.
STATISTICS OF PEOPLE IN THE
RECIDIVISM ISSUE. THANK YOU
CERTAINLY A CONTRACT IN THE IN
THE STATE GOVERNMENT HAS. HAS
SOME SOME ISSUES OFTEN
DEPARTMENTS ARE REQUIRED TO
CHOOSE THE LOS BANOS ABOUT
CREATIVE. ISSUES OCCASIONALLY
OF NON PERFORMANCE BY VENDORS
ON THE PART OF THE CAME OUT
WITH FROM REGARDING HARMON REAL
ESTATE OF PROGRAMS. QUESTIONED
SOME OF THE- SOME OF THE VENDOR
PERFORMANCE AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT'S ROLE OR BACK
ACTION IN MONITORING THOSE
CONTRACTS AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE VENDORS ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. MY OFFICE OF THIS
IS SERVICES WHICH OVERSEES
CONTRACTING FOR NON NINETEEN.
SERVICES DOES A LOT OF UP FRONT
TRAINING OF INSTITUTIONAL SOUTH
GENERALLY THE OFFICE OF
BUSINESS SERVICES IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROCESSING THE
CONTRACTS. MAKING SURE THEY
MEET ALL OF THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE PUBLIC CONTRACT CODE. BUT
WE ALSO HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE FOLKS OUT
OF THE PROGRAM'S MONITORING THE
CONTRACTS HOW. SCHOOLS. AND
ABILITY MAKES THE BAY. OUR MARK
CONTACT. CAMANCHE CONTRACTS
PARKS PLAY AND IN DOING SO WE
PROVIDE TRAINING TO THEM WE
ALSO. PARTICIPATE IN DEPARTMENT
GENERAL SERVICES GOLDEN STATE
WORK GROUP WHICH- IS IT A VENUE
TO BRING FORWARD CONCERNS ABOUT
THE CONTRACTING PROCESS AND ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT HAVE THE
HAVE HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP BY
MY- CONTRACTING STUFF OR THIS
ISSUE OF NON OF INTERNAL
COMPLAINTS IN WAYS THAT WE
COULD POSSIBLY. EITHER. ATTY TO
THE CONTRACTS ALLOW US TO. VERY
RESPONSIVE AND MANY OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENTS HAVE SIMILAR
PROBLEMS AND SO. WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON IT. KIND
OF A WORK IN PROGRESS. THANK
YOU AND ARE YOU WILL HAVE MY
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU A
CENTER MINING. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MISS OSBORNE
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAD A CHANCE TO
HAVE A GOOD CONVERSATION WAS IT
YESTERDAY OR TODAY YESTERDAY. I
DID WANT TO JUST CIRCLE BACK.
PRIOR TO YEAR TENURE IN THIS
POSITION THE STATE PERSONNEL
BOARD ON IT FOUND THAT SIX
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO MANAGERS HAD
NOT COMPLETED SEXUAL HARASSMENT
TRAINING. THE SECRETARY HAS
REPRESENTED THAT ALL MANAGERS
HAVE NOW RECEIVED. TRAINING SIX
RESTAURANT PREVENTION TRAINING
HOWEVER THE LAWN ON CALIFORNIA
DOES REQUIRE A TRAINING FOR ALL
EMPLOYEES COULD YOU GIVE US AN
UPDATE ON THE STATUS OF
ACHIEVING THAT OBJECTIVE.
CERTAINLY AFTER THE STATE
PERSONAL BOARD ON IT WAS
RELEASED. AND THEN THERE WAS A
SUBSEQUENT ARTICLE THE CAME OUT
EARLIER THIS YEAR THAT THEY USE
THE DATA AS THE BASIS WE KIND
OF DOVE AND LOOKED AT WHAT WHAT
WHAT WERE THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
FALLEN THROUGH THE GAPS IN WHAT
WAS GOING ON AND THE EVENTUAL
OUTCOME OF THE OUTLOOK. WE HAD
A BIFURCATED SYSTEM WE HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT TRAIN NEW STAFF IN
A SYSTEM A SEPARATE DIVISION
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR TRAINING
THE REPEATED ONGOING STOP EVERY
TWO SINCE I WAS SOME OF THE
DIFFICULTY WITH GETTING THE
DATA TO MATCH UP. RECENTLY
THOSE THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THE TRACKING ABOUT TRAINING AND
WAS APPROVED. ON SERVICE UNDER
SINGLE DIVISION WHICH WE
BELIEVE ALL MAKE IT. MAKE IT
EASIER TO TRACK THE DATA AND
THEN AT THE SAME TIME WHILE
WE'RE GETTING READY FOR THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR A HIGH OF THE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT PREVENTION
TRAINING BY JANUARY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY THE DEPARTMENTS
OF THE GOAL OF ACQUIRING
EVERYONE TO COMPLETE IT BY
OCTOBER FIRST SO THAT WE CAN
RUN THE DATA AFTERWARDS AND
MAKE SURE THAT IF ANYONE HAS
FALLEN THROUGH THE CRACKS WE
CATCH THEM AND BECOME. FULLY
COMPLIANT BUT MY FIRST THANK
YOU. THAT IS ENCOURAGING I
APPRECIATE THAT COMMITMENT AND
EFFORT. I KNOW SOME OF THE WORK
WE'VE DONE WITHIN. THE
LEGISLATURE. EACH WORKPLACE
PRESENTS UNIQUE CHALLENGES
DIFFERENT EMPLOYEE
CLASSIFICATIONS DIFFERENT
WORKING CIRCUMSTANCES.
LEGISLATION WE PASSED A FEW
YEARS AGO REQUIRES FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS TO PROVIDE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION TRAINING.
WE LEARNED THAT THEY WERE USING
VIDEO SIR. VISUAL AIDS
REFLECTING OFFICE SETTINGS IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES
NOT REALLY REPLICATING
CONDITIONS IN AGRICULTURAL
FIELDS AND I JUST HOPE AS YOU
MOVE FORWARD THIS IS MORE OF A
STATEMENT THAN A QUESTION THAT
EVEN WITHIN CDC ARE THEY'RE
VERY DIFFERENT WORKING
ATMOSPHERES IN CONDITIONS IN
WHEN YOU HAVE DIRECT CONTACT
WITH IN ME SOME OF THESE ISSUES
ARE ALSO A POTENTIALLY
PREVALENT THE END SO I HOPE YOU
CAN COMMIT TODAY TO KEEP US
INFORMED AS TO DATA YOU COLLECT
ON NOT JUST CHECKING THE BOXES
OF HOW MANY HAVE RECEIVED THE
TRAINING. BUT IS THERE ANY
COMMENSURATE REDUCTION IN
COMPLAINTS FILED THAT WOULD BE
OF INTEREST TO US MOVING
FORWARD IF YOU'RE WILLING TO
WORK WITH US ON THAT HAPPY TO
DO THAT AND DEFINITELY BRING IN
MY COLLEAGUE WHO IS OVER THAT
AREA IS TO PROVIDE YOU WITH ANY
SORT OF DATA REPORT AND THE
LIKE THANK YOU AND THEN JUST A
FINAL QUESTION NINE IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE ARE NO
LONGER CONTRACTING NO INMATES
ARE CURRENTLY BEING HOUSED AT
OF STATE IS THAT HAVE WE
ACHIEVED THAT OBJECTIVE OVERALL.
BROUGHT BACK STILL CALIFORNIA
AS OF JUNE THIRTIETH GREAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MAN PRO TEM
NO FURTHER QUESTIONS I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IN TODAY THANKS
THANK YOU TOM I APPRECIATE THE
TIME YOU SPENT WITH MY STAFF AS
WELL YESTERDAY I LOOK FORWARD
TO THE CONFIRMATION AND WITH
THAT I WILL ASK FOR PEOPLE IN
SUPPORT I TO COME UP AND. LET
ME LET YOU KNOW THIS IS GOING
WELL SO I. I'M SURE MISS
OSBORNE IS HAPPY TO SEE PROCEED
QUICKLY ANYONE IN SUPPORT. IN
OPPOSITION HER YOUR YOUR
HUSBAND'S IN SUPPORT I. HE
RAISED HIS HAND. THAT'S GOOD TO
KNOW. IN OPPOSITION. OKAY
SEEING NONE THANK YOU SENATOR
ROSS HAS MADE THE MOTION MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS BATES. BATES AYE A
MINING MONNING AYE ROTH ROUGH I
WILL WILK AYE ATKINS SIGN.
CONGRATULATIONS UNANIMOUS. LET
ME INVITE THE NEXT TWO
APPOINTEES UP MISTER MCGUIRE
MISTER FIRESTONE PLEASE COME UP
AND START TO GET SITUATED AS
PEOPLE ARE EXITING. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. SO LET ME GO
AHEAD AND INVITE YOU TO START
LET EACH OF YOU WE WILL TAKE
YOU TOGETHER IF THAT IS OKAY
AND WILL START WITH YOU MS
FIRESTONE INTRODUCE ANYONE YOU
LIKE OPENING COMMENTS THEY WILL
MOVE TO YOU MISTER MCGUIRE AND
THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT INTO IT.
WELCOME. OKAY. THANK YOU MADAM
FOR TIME AND SENATORS I'D LIKE
SAID. TODAY MY HUSBAND JUST
MAKING NATHAN AND MY MOTHER IN
LAW AND FATHER IN LINE ON ME
AND NATHAN MAKE ANYTHING SHORT
HERE TRYING TO MEET TODAY.
WELCOME I COME TO THIS
COMMITTEE WITH GREAT RESPECT
AND HUMILITY FOR THE ROLE THAT
I'VE BEEN APPOINTED TO SERVE.
THE DECISION THAT COMP THAT THE
DECISIONS THAT COME BEFORE THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD PROFOUNDLY SHAPE OUR
COMMUNITY IS OUR ECONOMY IS THE
RIVERS AND WATERSHEDS THAT WE
FISH AND SWIM AND EVEN THE
WATER THAT WE DRINK. AS A BOARD
WE HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROTECT AND ENHANCE OUR WATER
RESOURCES FOR CURRENT AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS. BALANCING
ALL OF BENEFICIAL USES.
CONSERVING EVERY REGION OF THE
STATE. AND NOT REALITY. IN THE
FACE OF CLIMATE CHANGE DROUGHTS
FIRES EARTHQUAKES ONLY BRINGS
MORE URGENCY TO OUR MISSION. AS
I HAVE TRANSITION INTO THIS NEW
ROLE AS A PUBLIC SERVANT I HAVE
SOUGHT OUT OPPORTUNITIES TO
LEARN FROM A DIVERSE SIDE OF
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC STAKEHOLDERS
THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED BY OUR
DECISIONS. MORE THAN ANYTHING I
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A LOT
AT STAKE. AND THAT I. HOT I
CONTINUED TO HAVE A LOT TO
LEARN. AND WITHOUT I WANTED TO
KEEP MY OPENING REMARKS SHORT
TIME AND APPRECIATE THE TIME
THAT EACH OF YOU AND YOUR STAFF
HAVE SPENT WITH ME THROUGH THIS
PROCESS AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU MISTER GAAR. AFTERNOON I'M
ADAM PRO TEM AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO AND SHE'S
MY WIFE AMANDA MCGUIRE. AN
AUDIENCE THE US TODAY. SO MY
CAREER AS AN ENGINEER HAS BEEN
FOUNDED ON SOLVING COMPLEX
WATER PROBLEMS AND I'M HONORED
TO BRING THAT EXPERIENCE TO THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD. TODAY IN TWENTY NINETEEN
WE ARE UNIQUELY POSITIONED AT
THE STATE WATER BOARD TO CHIEF
SOLUTIONS AND BALANCE ARE
LIMITED WATER RESOURCES THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS. WITH OTHER
AGENCIES WATER USERS
ENVIRONMENTAL AND COMMUNITY
ADVOCACY GROUPS AND NEW AND
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO RESTORE OUR
WATER WAYS. TO ACHIEVE
SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT. ENTER DATA THAT
AFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE WE'RE
ALSO EXCITED THAT NOW HAVE NEW
TOOLS AND FUNDING TERROR
URGENTLY ADDRESS A CRITICAL
NEED TO ASSURE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. IN ALL THESE
CHALLENGES ON THEIR OWN THERE
ARE ENORMOUS AND NONE OF THEM
WILL BE SOLVED OVERNIGHT. BUT
BY PER ACTIVELY SEEKING
COLLABORATIVE SOLUTIONS WE WILL
ENABLE CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE
TO THRIVE AS- THE WORLD'S FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY. ONE OF MY
PRIORITIES ON THE BOARD IS TO
CONTINUE TO SEPARATE A CULTURE
OF INNOVATION AND PROVIDING
NEEDED TOOLS TO PREPARE FOR THE
INEVITABLE. NEXT DROUGHT IN
DEPTH TO CLIMATE CHANGE. WE
NEED TO BETTER SUPPORT
STRATEGIC USE OF WATER TO
ACHIEVE MULTIPLE BENEFITS. BY
CAPTURING FLOOD FLOWS TO HELP
REDUCE FLOOD RISK LAW
INCREASING GROUNDWATER RECHARGE
AND RECONNECTING LAST
FLOODPLAIN HABITATS. TO BE
CERTAIN. I AM OPEN TO NEW IDEAS
AND SOLUTIONS AND COMMITTED THE
CALIFORNIA AND ITS BRIGHT
FUTURE AND HONORED TO HAVE A
ROLE IN THE STATE WATER BOARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
US SENATOR MINING. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND TO BOTH
CANDIDATES CONGRATULATIONS AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING WILLING TO
TAKE YOUR AMAZING CAREERS
RESPECTIVELY YOU BOTH HAVE JUST
SUCH AN AMAZING. CREDENTIALS
THAT YOU'RE BRINGING NOW TO
SERVE SERVICE ON THE WATER
BOARD I WANT TO THANK YOUR
FAMILIES WELCOME THEM THANK
THEM FOR THEIR SUPPORT IN YOUR
SUCCESS AND THANK THEM IN
ADVANCE FOR WHAT YOU WILL AND
DO WERE AS HERE LOVED ONES
SERVE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
LET ME START WITH THE QUESTION.
TO MS FIRESTONE IN IN EITHER
WON'T MOVE THE SAME QUESTION TO
MISTER MCGUIRE MAYBE I'LL GIVE
YOU A DIFFERENT ONE STARTING.
WITH MISS FIRESTONE YOU TAKE
YOUR POSITION ON THE BOARD AT
THE TIME OF IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE NEW SAFE CLEAN DRINKING
WATER FUND YOU WERE ONE OF THE
CRITICAL COAL ARCHITECTS FOR
YEARS MOVING THIS FORWARD MANY
YEARS SPENT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WORKING WITH FAMILIES.
FOR WHOM YOU DIDN'T HAVE
IMMEDIATE ANSWERS AND I WATCHED
YESTERDAY THE HEARING THAT YOU
BOTH SAT ON THE BOARD THAT WAS
DISCUSSING IMPLEMENTATION. OF
SB TWO HUNDRED AND TWELVE WE.
CELEBRATE THE ACHIEVEMENT OF A
FUNDING SOURCE THE REAL WORK
REALLY STARTS NOW AND IT'S
REALLY IN YOUR HANDS AND SO
MISS FOR SOME ME THIS CAN A
THIRTY THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL HOW
DOES THE BOARD MOVE FORWARD NOW
WITH RESOURCES ECONOMIC
RESOURCES BUT A CHESS BOARD OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHERE.
COMMUNITIES WE'RE LOOKING FOR
HELP YESTERDAY IN WE'LL BE
LOOKING FOR HELP TOMORROW HOW
HOW DOES THE BOARD MOVE FORWARD
ON THIS. YEAH THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE AND FOR THE WORK THIS
LEGISLATURE DEAD AND IN GIVING
US THIS CRITICAL RESOURCE WE
FELL A LOT OF RESPONSIBILITY TO
BE GOOD STEWARDS OF THIS FIND.
ENSURE THAT ITS USE TO.
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS ON THE
PROBLEMS THAT FACE MORE THAN A
MILLION CALIFORNIANS AND TIME
CREATE SOLUTIONS THAT WILL
TRULY LAST. WE HAVE A VARIETY
OF STRATEGIES THAT WE ARE
UTILIZED SEEN AS PART OF OUR
SAFE AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM WE HAVE. PERMITTING IN
COMPLIANCE ENFORCEMENT
OVERSIGHT WE HAVE I'M A NUMBER
OF CAPITAL AS FUNDING SOURCES
THAT WE HADN'T BEEN ABLE TO USE
BUT NOW THAT WE HAVE THE CIGNA
FOR DOUBLE DRINKING WATER FIND
WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE. MORE
COMPREHENSIVE AS SOLUTION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
ADMINISTRATOR SERVICES AND
SUPPORT FOR CONSOLIDATIONS.
THAT CAN UNLOCK MUCH OF THAT
CAPITAL FUNDING. AND WE HAVE A
ROBUST I TRACKING IN AND PUBLIC
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM THAT
WE'RE CONTINUING TO BUILD A TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE FUNDS THAT
WE DO USE OUR RESULTING IN REAL
OUT COMES FOR THE COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE THAT DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING
WATER AND TO BE ACCOUNTABLE
FOR. THE FUNDS THAT WE ARE
GIVEN AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY MORE QUESTIONS IN IN
MAYBE JUST TO FOLLOW UP WITH
YOU AND THEN I WILL HAVE A
QUESTION FOR MR MCGUIRE I KNEW
YOUR RECENTLY SEATED ON THE
BOARD BUT- HOW WOULD YOU
DESCRIBE SEEN. ALIGNMENT OF
BOARD MEMBERS THE ABILITY TO
WORK TOGETHER QUITE SHOCKING
SHARED WITH ME AND I THOUGHT
THAT SHOULD BE SHARED WITH THE
PANEL JUST COMING YEAR. A SENSE
OF THE QUALIFICATIONS IN.
SPIRIT OF THAT BOARD YEAH I'VE
BEEN I'M REALLY HONORED TO BE
PART OF SUCH A DIVERSE GROUP I
THINK OF. AS AS- ENERGY AND I'M
THIS VALUE OF I'M TRANSPARENCY
AND THOUGHTFULNESS AND BALANCE
THAT I THINK IS TIME REALLY A
PRIVILEGE TO BE A PART OF. I
EACH MEMBER BRINGS DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES AND PERSPECTIVES I
AM BUT THERE'S REALLY A-
FEELING ON THE BOARD UNDER NEW
LEADERSHIP WITH AND- ASK ABOUT
AND YOUR COLLEAGUES THAT TIME.
ARE LOOKING AT THINGS IN IN NEW
WAYS AND REALLY LOOKING INTO
THAT MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
CONTINUING TO BUILD THE. THE
TRUST I'M IN OUR INSTITUTIONS
AND I'M CONTINUE TO IMPROVE THE
WATER RESOURCES FOR STATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND MISTER
MCGUIRE YOU LOOTED IT ALLUDED
TO THIS IN YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT AND MAYBE A LITTLE
TOUGHER QUESTION BUT IS
CALIFORNIA FACES THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. A DROUGHT STATE
INCREASED FIRE HAZARD IN YEAR
ROUND FIRE SEASON WE HAVE.
MICRO WATER SYSTEMS AND THEN
MASSIVE STATEWIDE SYSTEMS AS AN
ENGINEER DO YOU LOOK AT THIS AS
MULTIPLE PROBLEMS TO SOLVE HER
HELD IT NOT FEEL ABSOLUTELY
OVERWHELMING TO YOU. BUT WE
HAVE A GREAT TEAM THAT SUPPORTS
US AND WERE CLEARLY GOING TO BE
RAMPING UP OUR STAFFING OVER
THE COMING MONTHS YOU KNOW.
CERTAINLY THERE'S NOT A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL SOLUTION FOR ALL
OF THESE COMMUNITIES THERE ARE
IN DIFFERENT AREAS AND EXPOSED
TO DIFFERENT CHALLENGES IN
TERMS OF THE WATER QUALITY
RISKS THAT THEY FACE AND THE
APPARENT RISKS OF FROM AS HE'S
A WILDFIRE AND CLIMATE CHANGE
SO WE NEED TO BE LOOKING AT ALL
THOSE FACTORS YOU KNOW THE
OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AND HAZARDS ASSESSMENT JUST
YESTERDAY AND FAILED. A DRAFT
TOOL WHICH LOOKS AT THE RISKS
THAT COMMUNITIES ARE FACING IN
TERMS OF WATER AND SO YOU KNOW
IT'S A DRAFT IN IN ITS
CONTINUED GOING TO CONTINUE TO
BE REFINED BUT IT'S PART OF OUR
INITIATIVE TO GET INFORMATION
OUT THERE TO UNDERSTAND REALLY
THE CHALLENGES THAT ARE FACING
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES AND WHAT
TYPES OF SOLUTIONS WILL WORK
YEAH WE HAVE A LOT OF TOOLS IN
THE TOOLBOX. IN TERMS OF
CONSOLIDATIONS WHETHER IT'S
ACTUAL PHYSICAL CONSOLIDATION
SO SYSTEMS OR ITS FUNCTIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE CONSOLIDATIONS
YOU KNOW GETTING COMPLETE
COMMUNITIES TO WORK TOGETHER
ACROSS BROADER GEOGRAPHIES SO
THERE'S YOU KNOW A LOT OF
OPTIONS THAT WILL BE LOOKING AT
AND CERTAINLY THERE'S GONNA BE
SOME GROWING PAINS AND IT'S
GOING TO TAKE SOMETIME TO BUILD
MOMENTUM. AS THE PROGRAM IS
ROLLED OUT BUT I IT'S IMPORTANT
AND I'M LOOKING. FOR TO BROUGHT
MY SLEEVES ON THAT. THANK YOU
IN ONE OF THE. ONE OF OUR-
BIGGEST INDUSTRIES IS
AGRICULTURE ALSO A BIG WATER
USER. AGRICULTURE DID NOT END
UP BEING PART OF THE SOLUTION
SENATE BILL TWO HUNDRED
DIRECTLY. BUT WE DO KNOW THAT.
SOME OF THE CONTAMINATION NOT
ALL CAN BE TRACED TO NITRATES
IN OTHER AG CHEMICALS. HOW DO
YOU SEE THE BOARD MOVING
FORWARD. TO CONTINUE TO. WORK
WITH BUT ALSO. IN FORCE
COMPLIANCE WITH AGRICULTURAL
WATER USERS. WELL YOU KNOW WE
ARE AT THE ANNA AT THE CORE WE
ARE A REGULATORY AGENCY AND WE
ARE IN OFTENTIMES IN WATER THE
FINAL BACKSTOP IN TERMS OF
ENSURING. THAT WE'RE PROTECTING
OUR WATER FOR ALL BENEFICIAL
USES. FOR AGRICULTURE INCLUDED
AS WELL AS. HUMAN HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT SO YOU KNOW I
MEAN BUT I'M LOOKING FOR A
COLLABORATIVE SOLUTIONS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH AGRICULTURE
THERE HAVE BEEN NUMEROUS
DISCUSSIONS IN THAT REGARD
ACROSS THE STATE. I THINK YOU
KNOW WE HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
THINKING TO DO NOW WITH WITH SB
TWO HUNDRED AND THAT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AND HOW THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS ARE GOING TO
BUILD ANY FALL FROM THERE AND
HOW WE CAN ALL CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER. BECAUSE I THINK WE
ALL HAVE THE SAME GOAL IN MIND
WHICH IS TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
ARE DRINKING SAFE HAVE ACCESS
TO SAFE DRINKING WATER AND TO
DO THAT AS QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE. THANK
YOU AND I'LL JUST CONCLUDE
MADAM CHAIR MISFIRE SO MAYBE
THE SAME QUESTION I JUST WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT A LOT OF
THE SUCCESS OF YOUR WORK WAS
WORKING WITH AGRICULTURAL
LEADERS IN. MULTIPLE CROPS AND
DAIRY AND- MAYBE JUST A COMMENT.
SHINJI TO HELP WITH THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY THANK
YOU YEAH I WOULD LIKE TO REALLY
ACKNOWLEDGE THE LEADERSHIP THAT
AS MANY LEADERS WITHIN THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY IT IS
STUCK THEIR NECKS OUT AND
WORKED WITH FOLKS THAT TIME
THEY MAY NOT HAVE I HAVE WORKED
WITH IN THE PAST. AND THERE IS
A REALLY UNIQUE AS. GROUP AND
COALITION THAT CAME TOGETHER.
TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THE AWKWARD
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
SAFE DRINKING WATER AND I THINK
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN.
AGRICULTURE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE I'M COMMUNITY IS SEND
AN ADVOCATES HELPED. AS BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS A MOMENTUM AROUND
THIS ISSUE THAT I BELIEVE WILL
CONTINUE I THINK THERE'S A REAL
COMMITMENT WITH AN AGRICULTURE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR PART
AS- ON SOLUTIONS. TO THIS ISSUE
AND I HOPE TO SEE THAT CONTINUE
THANKS. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU AND CONGRATULATIONS
TO BOTH OF YOU FILE FOR ON A
YEAR ON. NOMINATION FOR THESE
POSITIONS AND THEY'RE VERY VERY
IMPORTANT AND I HAD THOUGH THE
PLEASURE OF MEETING WITH BOTH
OF YOU IN MY OFFICE AND COVERED
MOST OF ARE THE ISSUES BUT I
THINK OUR WHAT I'D LIKE TO
BRING OUT TODAY FOR THE PUBLIC
TO ANSWER US YOUR ANSWERS TO
GIVE US. YOUR THOUGHTS AND FOR
SMALL START WITH YOU MISTER
MCGUIRE ON THE QUESTION OF SB
TWO HUNDRED MAYBE THIS IS FOR
BOTH OF YOU WHAT HAS ALWAYS
TROUBLED ME WHEN WE APPROVE OF
FUNDING FOR YOU KNOW VERY
WORTHWHILE PROJECTS A LOT OF IT
GET SUCKED UP BY ADMINISTRATIVE
OVERSIGHT IN THE PLANNING
PROCESS. HOW WILL YOU AS BOARD
MEMBERS ENSURE THAT THE
APPROPRIATION IS MORE HEAVILY
ON ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF THE
PEOPLE AND THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY RECEIVING ALL THE
BENEFITS WHICH IS CLEAN
DRINKING WATER WHAT WHAT ARE
YOU GOING TO BE LOOKING AT. IN
TERMS OF YOUR DIRECTION TO YOUR
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF ON THAT.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I
KNOW A FOR WHEN THAT THERE ARE
LIMITATIONS ON THE AMOUNT OF
THE- FUNDING THAT CAN BE
DIRECTED TOWARDS ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS. HOWEVER THIS THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK INVOLVED WITH THIS
IT'S GOING TO INVOLVE.
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM YOU KNOW
ACROSS OUR STAFF AND ENGAGING
WITH CONTRACTORS ENGINEERS
CONSULTANTS ACROSS THE STATE
FRANKLY TO MAKE THIS COME TO
FRUITION. SO IT IS GOING TO
HAVE COSTS. THAT BEING SAID
THAT THE BILL IS VERY CLEAR ON
TRANSPARENCY AND OUR BOARD IS
VERY COMMITTED TO TRANSPARENCY.
WITH THE FISCAL EXPENDITURES
YOU KNOW WE'RE ALREADY VERY
PRACTICE THAT THAT WITH THEIR
DIVISION OF FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE AND OUR- STATE
REVOLVING FIND. PROGRAMS AND
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT WITH SB TWO HUNDRED
THERE'LL BE REGULAR REPORTING
ON OUR WEBSITE AS TO THE
FUNDING EXPENDITURES. A. NOW
WHEREAS THE MANY BEEN COMMITTED
AND WHERE YOU KNOW WHAT OF THE
SUCCESSES THAT WE'RE SEEING.
THERE'S ALSO GOING TO BE A VERY
STAKEHOLDER DRIVEN AND- FUNDING
UP FOR IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
THAT'S GONNA BE DEVELOPED OVER
THE NEXT COMING MONTHS. WHICH
IS GOING TO BUILD ON INPUT FROM
THE COMMUNITY FROM WATER
SYSTEMS THAT ARE IMPACTED IN
TERMS OF HOW BEST. TO USE THESE
FUNDS SO. IT THERE'S GIVE ME A
LOT OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT
THERE'S BEEN ACT HIDING
ANYTHING THAT ALL THE
INFORMATION IS GOING TO BE
SHARED AND CERTAINLY. WILL BE
LOOKING AT WAYS TO CONTROL
COSTS AS. MUCH AS POSSIBLE TO
MAKE SURE IT'S GETTING TO THOSE
WHO NEED IT MOST. HE THEN
MISFIRE STONE YOUR THOUGHTS.
YEAH AS. IN MY PRIOR LIFE I A I
WAS ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THINGS
SEEN FRUSTRATION WITH THAT.
FROM COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
APPLYING FOR FUNDING AND NOT
SEEN IT COMING INTO THE
COMMUNITY IS THAT HAVE BEEN
WAITING FOR AND SOMETIMES
DECADES FOR FUNDING NECESSARY
TO SOLVE THEIR CHALLENGES AND
SO. I AM ACUTELY AWARE OF THAT
URGENT NEED TO AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF MAKING SURE THAT
OUR PUBLIC FUNDING IS GETTING
TO WHERE IT NEEDS TO GO I'M AND
THERE IS I FEEL PERSONALLY
RESPONSIBLE FRANKLY FOR MAKING
SURE THAT THIS PROGRAM. IS
SUCCESSFUL AND RESULTS IN REAL
OUT COMES FORWARD THE COMMUNITY
IS THAT FRANKLY HELPED FIGHT TO
GET THIS FUND TO BEGIN WITH I'M.
AND NEED TO BE THE RECIPIENTS
OF THE BENEFITS. GREAT WILL
THAT ARE KIND OF THIS GREAT
SEGUE INTO MY NEXT QUESTION FOR
YOU MISS FIRESTONE YOU ARE
VIEWED BY SLIMY AND- WITH FLAT
FEE THE TENSION THAT GOES ON.
IN THE WHOLE WATER WORLD OF
FIVE MINISTRATION AND CERTAINLY
ON THE R. AG PEOPLE. VERSUS THE
CONTROL LET'S PUT ON A WATER
FLOW AND ALL OF THAT THROUGH
THE- THE VARIOUS WATER OR SEND
THE REGIONAL WATER BOARD
SANDERS STATE SO SHARE WITH ME
AND YOU DID IN THE OFFICE BUT
TIED LIKE TO HEAR ON THE-
PUBLIC RECORD YOUR THOUGHTS
ABOUT HOW. YOU WILL HAVING BEEN
AN ADVOCATE. ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THAT. OR MENTAL ARE HOW YOU
WILL BALANCE. YOUR DECISION
MAKING IS NOW PART OF THAT
BECAUSE I. JUDICIAL REGULATORY
STRUCTURE OF THE BOARD MAKING
DECISIONS AND ENSURING THAT
THEY ARE. DODD DOES DID SHE
EVEN AND JOHN. INCORPORATE
BALLOT SAY SHE LOOK AT BOTH
SIDES OF THE ISSUES BECAUSE YOU
WERE ON THE OTHER SIDE. OF THE
DICE OUT OF THE PUBLIC WITH
YOUR THREE MINUTES PROBABLY TO
BE ABLE TO SPEAK OF HER FROM
BOARD. SO IT DIE SHARE WITH US
ALL OF US ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THAT YEAH THANK YOU SO MUCH. I
AS- I HAVE. FOR MUCH OF MY
CAREER AND SEEN THE NECESSITY
OF REALLY LISTENING TO FOLKS
EVEN WHEN YOU DON'T AGREE WITH
THEM AND TRULY TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. AND WHERE THERE IS
COMMON GROUND WHERE THERE MAY
BE UNINTENDED. CONSEQUENCES AND
UNDERSTANDING THE TRIM CATION
THAT THE. I'M ANY BODY MAKES
AND SO NOW THAT I AM IN THIS
NEW ROLE I AM VERY COGNIZANT OF
THAT OF THE REAL HIGH STAKES
FOR EVERYONE INVOLVED THE NEED
TO REALLY ENGAGE AND
UNDERSTAND. I'M THAT DIFFERENT
HAD CHALLENGES AND POTENTIAL
IMPACTS FROM FIVE PROPOSALS OR
DECISIONS IN FRONT OF US. I'M
AND. AT I ALSO REALLY BELIEVE
IN TRYING TO BUILD TRUST INTO
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS SO
FOR EXAMPLE AND- THE FEUD
DECISION MAKING PROCEEDINGS I'M
IN WHICH I WAS PERSONALLY
INVOLVED I AM RECUSING MYSELF
AND NOT PARTICIPATING IN I FEEL
IT IT'S VERY IMPORTANT. TO
BUILD A STRONG I'M- THE STRONG
SENSE OF TRUST IN THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS AND SO EVEN
THOUGH I WOULDN'T BE REQUIRED
TO I AM I AM AND CHOOSING NOT
TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT AS A AND
YEAH I'D APPRECIATE THE AS THIS
MAJOR CHANGE IN ROLE AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT IT BRINGS.
THANK YOU AND I BELIEVE YOU ARE
YOU IN OUR ONE ON ONE
CONVERSATION NOW WE'RE VERY
CONVINCING ON THAT I THINK I
SHARED WITH YOU THEN AS FAR
SOME SINCE I NEED TO DOUBLE
BACK AND CHECK WITH THE
CONSTITUENTS TO RAISE THIS
ISSUE WITH ME. TODAY I WILL
JUST ABSTAINED BUT BY THE TIME
I GET TO THE FLOOR I THINK
WE'LL BE COMFORTABLE AND AFTER
MY CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM AND
I THINK THEY MAY HAVE HAD SOME
WITH YOU ALSO. SO YOU DO BRING
OUR WEALTH OF KNOWLEDGE HAVING
BEEN ON THAT OTHER SIDE WHERE I
USED TO BE BY THE WAY. AND NOW
MY CAREER I WAS THE ONE THAT
USED TO GO AND BEAT UP ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISOR OVER A LOT
OF ISSUES AND THEN I BECAME LAW
AND SO IT WAS THAT YOU WITHIN
EIGHTEEN TEN AND YOU DO GET A
BROADER PERSPECTIVE HAVING
SERVED ON BOTH SIDES SO I KNOW
THAT YOU BRING THAT. A LAST
QUESTION FOR YOU MISTER MCGUIRE
IT'S ABOUT THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS AND I THINK WE
TALKED ABOUT THAT VERSES THE
WILL REGION REGULATORY APPROACH
THAT WAS THROUGH PHASE ONE ON
THE WATER FLOW ISSUES AND- THE
BAY DELTA AND IF YOU WOULD
SHARE WITH US YOUR THOUGHTS ON.
VOLUNTARY. VERSUS THE MORE. ARE
STRUCTURED. I THINK IF I
REMEMBER A YEAR CONVERSATIONS
THAT. YOU BELIEVE THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS BRING EVERYONE
TOGETHER HE IS PROBABLY A
BETTER APPROACH HI AS WE GOING
FACE TO. I REMEMBER THAT
CORRECTLY AND TO SHARE SOME OF.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT ISSUE DID
WITH ME. SURE SB HAPPY TO. SELL
YES CERTAINLY THE BAY DELTA
WATERSHED HAS BEEN IN THE STATE
OF THE CLIENT ECOSYSTEMS BEEN
IN DECLINE FOR. SEVERAL DECADES
NOW YOU KNOW DESPITE ALL OF
OUR- BEST EFFORTS TO TRY AND
RESTORE THAT IN TURN TURN THE
TIDE. AND HELP RESTORE
FISHERIES AND THE ECOSYSTEM.
AND YOU KNOW OVER THE PAST
EIGHT MONTHS AS A BOARD MEMBER
I'VE- TALK TO STAKEHOLDERS
ACROSS. BOTH AISLES I'VE TALKED
TO ENVIRONMENTAL NGO
REPRESENTATIVES OF TALK TO
AGRICULTURE I TALKED TO URBAN.
WATER SUPPLIERS AND I HAVE YOU
KNOW COME TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT YES INDEED YOU KNOW
VOLUNTARY APPROACH TO MANAGING
THAT INCREDIBLY COMPLEX WATERS
SAID IS YEAH THE PREFERRED AND
REALLY. I IN MY MIND ONE OF THE
ONLY PASSED THAT WE CAN TAKE
FORWARD TO ARRIVE AT MEANINGFUL
RESULTS WITHIN AND A NEED A
TIME FRAME BUT WE DON'T WANT TO
SEE IT MY FEAR IS THAT. YOU
KNOW IF. THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS ARTIST SUCCESSFUL
AND ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD THAT
WE'LL FIND OURSELVES AND A
PERIOD OF. OF LITIGATION FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND FRANKLY
THAT DOES NOTHING FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT. THAT BEING SAID
YEAH I DO WANT TO SAY THAT IT
IS ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT THAT
THE SCIENCE YOU KNOW AND THE
RIGOR BEHIND THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS IS ABLE TO SHOW.
THAT WE CAN MAKE PROGRESS IN
PROVIDE REASONABLE PROTECTION
FOR OFFICIAL WILDLIFE THAT IS
ABSOLUTE ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL
AND AS A BOARD MEMBER YOU KNOW
THAT'S MY RESPONSIBILITY. TO
ENSURE THAT THE BAY DELTA WATER
QUALITY CONTROL PLAN REPRESENTS
AND WE BELIEVE WILL ACHIEVE
THOSE OBJECTIVES SO I AM
COMMITTED TO WORK YOU KNOW WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS TO TRY AND-
ACCOMPLISH THOSE. MEANS AND YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO
DO BUT- I THINK WE CAN GET
THERE. WELL YOU'LL HAVE MY
SUPPORT I THINK YOU COME
FORWARD AND I THINK VERY
IMPRESSIVE. COMMENTED TO OUR
PROBLEM SOLVERS AND CERTAINLY
ENGINEERS LIKE TO WEAR THAT IN
ON THEIR LITTLE. LAPEL RIGHT
HERE I CAN GIVE THEM CAN BRING
IT OUT AND START. RIGHT NOW THE
SOLUTION SO WELCOME TO THE
BOARD AND NOW YOU'LL HAVE MY
SUPPORT. MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
CONGRATULATIONS SAID TO BOTH
THE AGAIN VERY IMPRESSIVE
RESUMES SO I. IN THE EARLIER
TESTIMONY THE PRO TEM MENTIONED
THAT WE REPRESENT ALL SENATORS
AND ONE OF THE PRACTICES THAT I
HAVE IS TO PUT IT OUT TO MY
CAUCUS MEMBERS THESE ARE THESE
ARE PEOPLE ARE COMING UP YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS PLEASE GET
INTO ME. UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU I DIDN'T GET
IT TILL LIKE AN HOUR AGO SO I
TYPICALLY DON'T ASK ANYTHING IN
PUBLIC THAT HAD ALREADY HAS
PRIVATELY SO I WANT TO
APOLOGIZE I'M SURE YOU CAN BE
FINE WITH IT AND CENTER MONEY
CONNOTATION ALREADY BUS OF
MAYBE CAN GIVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE SPECIFICITY FOR THIS
PARTICULAR SENATOR. SO REALLY
INTERESTED IN AND IF YOU COULD
YEAH WITH GREATER SPECIFICITY
POSSIBLE WHAT ROLE DO YOU
BELIEVE AGRICULTURE I CAN PLAY
IN THE SAFE DRINKING WATER ACT.
THIS IS A CONCERN OF ONE OF MY
MEMBERS. SURE. YOU KNOW I THINK
THERE THAT AGRICULTURE AND IT'S
ALREADY PLANE A MAJOR ROLE IN A
LOT OF AREAS AND IS WORKING AS
WITH MANY OF THE REGIONAL
BOARDS ON TRYING TO. ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE PROTECTING WATER
QUALITY THROUGH THEIR PRACTICES
THROUGH THE REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS AND IN SOME CASES
ARE ALREADY EVEN SUPPLYING
ENTER MODER SOURCES TO SOME
COMMUNITIES I THINK THERE'S A
IT LIKE I SAID A LOT OF
MOMENTUM AND RELATIONSHIPS
BUILT AND SO EVEN THOUGH WITH
THIS PARTICULAR FIND I'M THERE
IS NOT A DIRECT AGRICULTURAL
CONTRIBUTION I THINK THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES. TO CONTINUE TO
LOOK FOR THOSE AND I'M. I KNOW
THERE IS A I'M A FRAMEWORK
BEING DISCUSSED IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FOR EXAMPLE ABOUT TIME
LOOKING AT HOW AGRICULTURE CAN
PLAY A PARTICULAR ROLE AROUND
NAY TRAITS IN THAT REGION.
THANK YOU. NO THE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS SENATE ROTH. PHOTO BY
ACTUALLY. THANK YOU SENATOR LET
ME GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
AND ASK THOSE WHO ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT TO STEP FORWARD AND I
WOULD GREATLY APPRECIATE IT IF
YOU COULD GIVE YOUR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT. AND
YOUR SUPPORT. IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME I'M GOOD EVER. TRULY
ASK YOU TO KEEP IT SHORT. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS STEVE
BAKER WITH HER AND RENDON SAYS
HITS FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT WHICH INCLUDES THE
ENGINEERS THAT WORK AT THE
BOARD. ONE OF HOME THAT WAS
JUST THE RECENT PAST PRESIDENT
OF PEGS STATEWIDE YOU'RE GONNA
HEAR IT A LITTLE BIT MORE I'M
SURE BUT THANKS TO YOU AND
SENATOR MODDING FOR THE WORK
YOU DID ON SB TWO HUNDRED.
USUALLY YOU ALL HAVE SOME
FAMILIARITY WITH THESE FOLKS
AND COULD BE THE BEST JUDGES OF
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE GOOD MEMBERS IN THIS CASE I
KNOW THAT SENATOR MODDING SPENT
MANY MANY MANY HOURS WITH.
LAURELL ON PUTTING TOGETHER SB
TWO HUNDRED AND- TEN CREDIT
YOUR SUPPORT. Q. WELCOME. THANK
YOU TURN MEMBERS JONATHAN
NELSON WITH COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER PLEASED TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF BOTH BOARD MEMBER.
ACQUIRE AND FIRESTONE'S
CONFIRMATION AND- WE LOOKS
FORD'S EARLY TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND THE LEADERSHIP THAT
YOU'LL BRING TO THESE
CHALLENGING ISSUES. AND THEN.
NOT A SURPRISE BUT WE JUST ARE
SO PROUD. OF LARA BECAUSE WE
WOULD NOT BE HERE TODAY AND
CERTAINLY TAKES A VILLAGE AND-
THE LEADERSHIP THAT SOMEONE ON
THIS DíAS IS PART OF THE
PROGRESS WE MADE THIS YEAR. BUT
WE WOULD NOT BE HERE. BUT FOR
LAUREL AND YOU. MAKE US BETTER
YOU DEMONSTRATE THE VALUE OF
REACHING OUT TO THOSE THAT.
DON'T ALWAYS SHARE THE SAME
OPINION AND YOU BROUGHT SUCH
THOUGHT LEADERSHIP AND COURAGE
TO THIS WORK. I'M SO PROUD OF
YOU AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON THE
BOARD. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M ONLY LAMB FROM
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION WE WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH BOTH OF
MEMBERS OF FIRESTONE AND
REQUIRE ON THE BAY DELTA PLAN
AND ON SAFE DRINKING WATER AND
I THINK THE HIGHEST COMPLIMENT
THAT I CAN GIVE TO BOTH OF THEM
IS THAT WE HAVE NOT ALWAYS SEEN
EYE TO EYE ON EVERYTHING BUT
THAT OUR STAFF I REALLY
RESPECTED BOTH WHERE THEY'RE
COMING FROM AND ALSO HOW HOW
DEDICATED THEY ARE TO ON THE
WORK THAT THEY DO SO WE'RE HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORTER BEFORE THEM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WELCOME.
JEANNIE MINOR ON BEHALF OF
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF BOTH
MISTER MCGUIRE AND MISSED
FIRESTONE ESPECIALLY APPRECIATE
THE PERSPECTIVE THAT MISS
FIRESTONE BRINGS IN THE
COMMITMENT SHE HAD TO ACHIEVING
SAFE DRINKING WATER FOR ALL AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH. MISTER MCGUIRE SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CINDY TECH WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
PLEASED TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT.
OF BOTH BOARD MEMBER FIRESTONE
AND BOARD MEMBER MCGUIRE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS OF ROBERT CORPS FROM
THE GLOCK A GROUP ON BEHALF OF
THE MODESTO WE ARE CATION
DISTRICT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF WINE GRAPE
GROWERS THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
WATER QUALITY AUTHORITY INDIA
SOUTH COAST WATER DISTRICT FROM
ORANGE COUNTY. THEY'RE ALL IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF BOTH MEMBERS
FIRESTONE AND REQUIRE WE IF WE
FEEL THEY'RE THOUGHTFUL INTO IN
LEADERS OF THE FUTURE AND ALSO
OFFERING MY PERSPECTIVES IS A
FORMER GOVERNORS RESOURCES
ADVISOR. AND ENGINEERING FOR
VICE PRESIDENT YOU COULDN'T
HAVE TWO MORE CAPABLE TEAM
MEMBERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM PRO TEM
AND MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN ON
BEHALF OF THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION
VERY PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION
OF BOTH FOR MEMBER FIRESTONE
AND BOARD MEMBER REQUIRE THEY
BRING DIVERSE PERSPECTIVES
PROFESSIONAL EXPERTISE AND
EXPERIENCE THAT'S DIRECTLY
RELEVANT TO THE MANY
UNDERTAKINGS OF THE WAR CURLY
HAZARD WAY TO PROTECT
BENEFICIAL USES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. LOOK FOR. THEM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE
AFTERNOON MICHAEL CLAIBORNE ON
BEHALF OF LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
HERE IN SUPPORT OF BOTH BOARD
MEMBER FIRESTONE AND BOARD
MEMBER MCGUIRE AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THEM BOTH ON
DRINKING WATER SOLUTIONS AND
SOURCE PROTECTION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. DANIEL BUS AHEAD
WITH CALIFORNIA'S FOR UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION I'M GONNA SAY A
LITTLE SOMETHING DIFFERENT
ABOUT EACH ONE OF THEM. WE
APPRECIATE MISTER REQUIRES
BROAD TECHNICAL EXPERTISE AND
HIS ABILITY TO UNDERSTAND THE
COMPLICATED NATURE OF WATER IN
CALIFORNIA HIS BALANCED
APPROACH REALLY TAKES INTO THE
MERION VIEW POINTS THAT. ARE IN
THE WATER WORLD AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT AS FAR AS MISS
FIRESTONE WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TIRELESS DEDICATION TO
PROVIDING SAFE DRINKING WATER
FOR ALL AND I'M TO THE POINT
THAT A SENATOR BATES MADE
EARLIER YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
WATER LOSS WITH BOTH MEMBERS
BUT- IN PARTICULAR MISFIRE
STONE HAS BEEN WILLING. TO
LISTEN AND UNDERSTAND THE VERY
TECHNICAL ISSUE THAT IS WATER
LOSS IN CALIFORNIA I'M SO WE
APPRECIATE THAT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
BOTH. ON THE WATER. Q. CAITLYN
KALO OF THE CALIFORNIA COAST
KEEPER ALLIANCE I REPRESENTS
LOCAL WATERKEEPER ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND WE ARE
HERE SPEAKING A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF A LITTLE FIRESTONE
TODAY EYES CALIFORNIA'S FORWARD
TO RECTIFY THIS CURRENT
DRINKING WATER CRISIS REDUCE SO
THRILLED TO HAVE THIS PERSON ON
THE BOARD I'VE COULD NOT BE
MORE TIMELY OR FITTING QUITE
FRANKLY SO. THANK YOU WE
WELCOME THIS PERSON TO THE
BOARD. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CRAIG
JOHNSON HERE TODAY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES IN SUPPORT
OF THEIR CONFIRMATION. THANK
YOU. ONE OF THE MEAT ON A
WITHOUT A ONE CALIFORNIA
HEARING BOTH SUPPORT A BOARD
MEMBER MCGUIRE AND THEN
FIRESTONE WE BELIEVE THEM TO BE
THOUGHTFUL AND PRAGMATIC
INDIVIDUALS AND WE THINK THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE A GREAT
LEADERS AND SHOW GREAT
LEADERSHIP AND THE BOARD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. TUBMAN'S AND
THEY HAVE THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
ENGINEERING COMPANIES FOR
PARTICULARLY PROUD TO COUNT
MISTER MCGUIRE AS A FELLOW
ENGINEER AND A WONDERFUL
SUPPORT THANK YOU. YOU. FOR
CREW WAS THE CURE ON BEHALF OF
THE IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF BOTH A
BOARD MEMBER OF MCGUIRE AND
BOARD MEMBER PARSONS. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRYST A
GUARANTEE WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR MISTER
MCGUIRE AND- HIS FIRESTONE
WE'VE PARTICULARLY HAD AN
EXTENSIVE. ABILITY TO WORK WITH
ITS FIRESTONE IN HER PREVIOUS
ROLE AND HER COMMITMENT
DEDICATION AND LEADERSHIP ON
DRINKING WATER IS SO MUCH
APPRECIATED THAT WE ARE EXCITED
TO WORK WITH THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. JENNIFER CURRY ON BEHALF
OF CLEAN WATER ACTION IN
SUPPORT OF BOTH CANDIDATES AND
I'M SORRY SHAWN BUT I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH FLORA FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS SO. I'M KIND OF FEELING
THAT LITTLE BIT MORE. THANKS.
IT'S SAD A TWEENER I. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN RODRIGUEZ
WITH THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT A MISFIRE STERN WE'VE
WORKED WITH HER IN THE PAST ON
GROUND WATER SUSTAINABILITY
EDUCATION AND WE FOUND HER TO
BE EXTREMELY COMMITTED
THOUGHTFUL AND ENGAGING THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES SIR.
BRENNAN DAWSON WAS HERE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT OF
BOTH CANDIDATES IN THEIR
SECRETIVE TIME ON THE BOARD.
BUT THEY'VE BEEN EXTREMELY
SUCCESSFUL AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THEM TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL ECOSYSTEMS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON BETSY RIPE SNYDER
WITH THE MONO LAKE COMMITTEE.
AND WE ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT
BOTH CANDIDATES THANK YOU. YES
SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON AND FOR
THAT ALONE ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN A MINIMAL
DEFENSE FUND FOR ALL THE
REASONS ALREADY STATED IN
STRONG SUPPORT BOTH CANDIDATES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BOTTOM
PRO TEM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RICE COMMISSION
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL IN THE
SOUTH PHILLY WATER ASSOCIATION
TO BOTH CANDIDATES WE KNOW THAT
THEY ARE BALANCED REASONABLE
AND TRANSPARENT AND AS ONE THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT HIS DISAGREED
WITH MISS FIRESTONE ON A NUMBER
OF ISSUES OVER THE YEARS HOW WE
HAVE FOUND WAYS TO WORK
TOGETHER ON THE ISSUES THAT
WERE IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA AND I
DID HAVE THE HONOR OF SPENDING
MANY HOURS WITH HER AND IN
SEVEN OR MONEY WORKING THROUGH
THE ISSUES SAFE DRINKING WATER
AND- PROUD TO SUPPORT HER TODAY
AND WISH TO THE BEST OF LUCK.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. OKAY
SEEING NONE I'M HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION SENATOR
MINING. ALL RIGHT WE DO NEED TO
SPLIT THE VOTE SO WE WILL TAKE
ON. ITEM ONE SEE THAT WOULD BE
MS LAUREL FIRESTONE FIRST
EMOTION. SENATOR MINING AT IT
WHAT A COURTESY SENATOR MINING
MADAM SECRETARY SENATORS BATES.
MONNING MONNING AYE ROTH ROTH I
WILL HI WILK AYE ATKINS HI. WE
WILL ADD THAT IS HAS FOUR VOTES
NOW WE WILL LEAVE THE VOTE OPEN
AND CONGRATULATIONS. OKAY I WE
WILL MAYBE YOU'LL GIVE THE
COURTESY TO YOUR OTHER
COLLEAGUES HERE THANK YOU AND
THAT IS ON ITEM DE MISTER
MCGUIRE MADAM SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL. SENATORS BATES MINING.
MONNING AYE ROTH ROTH I WILL
WILK AYE ATKINS HI. HI AND WE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN BUT
YOU HAVE FOUR VOTES
CONGRATULATIONS. YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TO DO THE SESSION. SO
WE'RE GONNA RECESS INTO
EXECUTIVE SESSION. WE WILL GO
BACK INTO OPEN SESSION. TO
ALLOW OUR COLLEAGUE TO VOTE
WHEN SHE RETURNS BUT IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME. WE'RE GONNA.
GO INTO EXECUTIVE SET RECESS
INTO EXECUTIVE SESSION SO WE
WILL AWAIT
. GET THIS TIME WE'RE
GONNA LET THE CALL ON. ITEM ONE
RIGHT HERE ITEM ONE SEE.
SENATOR BATES. THE PHONE IS
FOUR ZERO THE VOTERS FOUR ZERO
THE NOMINEES CONF WANNA CONFIRM
SENT TO THE FLOOR UP NEXT IS
ITEM ONE D. SENATOR BATES.
BATES FIVE FIVE ZERO IT'S OUT
SO THAT IS OUT FIVE ZERO WILL
HEAD TO THE SENATE FLOOR. AND
GOING TO EXIT AND NOW WE'RE
GONNA ADJOURNING GO INTO
EXECUTIVE SESSION